So guys, welcome. It's time for another session of Smartless Cold Open. Yeah. And who would like to begin? Anybody want to begin? Willie's in hysterics over a joke that Sean just told that America, you cannot hear because if you did, you'd never like Sean Hayes again. Welcome to SmarterList.
So guys, welcome. It's time for another session of Smartless Cold Open. Yeah. And who would like to begin? Anybody want to begin? Willie's in hysterics over a joke that Sean just told that America, you cannot hear because if you did, you'd never like Sean Hayes again. Welcome to SmarterList.|||大家好，欢迎。又到了“Smartless 冷开场”时间。对。谁想先开始？有人想开始吗？威利对肖恩刚才讲的一个笑话笑得前仰后合，美国的朋友们，你们听不到这个笑话，因为如果听到了，你们就再也不会喜欢肖恩·海斯了。欢迎来到 SmarterList。
Ha ha ha! Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. JB., you look... J.B. looks like a guy with the glasses and the hat and the beard and the hair. He looks like he's just... He's spending the weekend. He's parked the van up in Bend, Oregon, right? He's up in Bend. He's going to do some windsurfing on the river
Ha ha ha! Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. JB., you look... J.B. looks like a guy with the glasses and the hat and the beard and the hair. He looks like he's just... He's spending the weekend. He's parked the van up in Bend, Oregon, right? He's up in Bend. He's going to do some windsurfing on the river|||哈哈哈哈！聪明。谎言。聪明。谎言。聪明。谎言。JB，你看起来……J.B.看起来像那种戴着眼镜、帽子、留着胡子和长发的人。他看起来就像……他正在过周末。他把面包车停在了俄勒冈州的本德，对吧？他在本德。他打算去河上玩风帆冲浪
at the gorge. It's disgusting. He's up at the gorge. These are frames. They look good, I like those frames. These are frames that you would see on Plastic Man if you're as old as I am. They're kind of tragically hip now
at the gorge. It's disgusting. He's up at the gorge. These are frames. They look good, I like those frames. These are frames that you would see on Plastic Man if you're as old as I am. They're kind of tragically hip now|||在峡谷。太恶心了。他在峡谷那边。这些镜框。看起来不错，我喜欢这种镜框。如果你和我一样老的话，这些镜框你在《塑料人》里都能看到。它们现在变得有一种悲剧色彩的赶时髦
that my wife made me get. I just keep them at the house, but I wore them today, and they're transition lenses, so they get that little smoky kinda half tint. And so, and so the problem is like, I'm keeping them at home so no one sees them, but I've been on Zooms all day, and so Will's just reminding me
that my wife made me get. I just keep them at the house, but I wore them today, and they're transition lenses, so they get that little smoky kinda half tint. And so, and so the problem is like, I'm keeping them at home so no one sees them, but I've been on Zooms all day, and so Will's just reminding me|||这是我老婆逼我买的。我平时都把它们放在家里，但今天我戴了，而且它们是变色镜片，所以带有一点烟熏似的那种半透明色。所以，所以问题是，我把它们放在家里就是为了不让别人看到，但我一整天都在开 Zoom 会议，所以威利刚刚提醒我
that I've looked like a frickin' douchebag all day. No, you don't. I said you look kinda crunchy. I didn't say you look like a douchebag. I said you look like you're up in Oregon. I got this hipster little trucker hat on and everything. The glasses look like you could have a neck tattoo. Yeah, bro.
that I've looked like a frickin' douchebag all day. No, you don't. I said you look kinda crunchy. I didn't say you look like a douchebag. I said you look like you're up in Oregon. I got this hipster little trucker hat on and everything. The glasses look like you could have a neck tattoo. Yeah, bro.|||我一整天看起来都像个混蛋。才没有呢。我说你看起来有点另类。我没说你看起来像个混蛋。我说你看起来就像是在俄勒冈州。我还戴着这种时髦的小卡车司机帽什么的。这眼镜看起来就像你有颈部纹身一样。没错，兄弟。
Right? You could be, that you live in Highland Park. Wait, let me ask you this. What's a part that you would never, never get asked to play or would want to have to play? Oh. Probably this guy. For real?
Right? You could be, that you live in Highland Park. Wait, let me ask you this. What's a part that you would never, never get asked to play or would want to have to play? Oh. Probably this guy. For real?|||对吧？你可能，就住在高地公园。等一下，我问你这个。有什么角色是你绝对、绝对不会被邀请去扮演，或者说根本不想去演的？哦。大概就是这种人吧。真的假的？
Well yeah, I mean the part I'm playing, I mean that's why I grew out this dumb ass beard and long hair is because I'm playing a guy that is, you know, he's got a drug history and he makes a lot of bad decisions. They usually get cast as like some smart, middle-aged white dick, you know? Anyway.
Well yeah, I mean the part I'm playing, I mean that's why I grew out this dumb ass beard and long hair is because I'm playing a guy that is, you know, he's got a drug history and he makes a lot of bad decisions. They usually get cast as like some smart, middle-aged white dick, you know? Anyway.|||嗯，对，我是说我演的角色，我是说这就是为什么我留了这该死的胡子和长发，因为我演的是一个，你知道的，有吸毒史而且经常做出糟糕决定的人。他们通常都被选去演那种精明的中年白人混蛋，你知道吗？总之。
Well we'll let the audience do the math on that one. You know what I mean? I was gonna do the math for you, but. Oh, you guys. Wait, so what's going on? Have you guys had the dumb, dumb, busy day like me? I mean, today is just like a cute comment. No, I had a super slow day today.
Well we'll let the audience do the math on that one. You know what I mean? I was gonna do the math for you, but. Oh, you guys. Wait, so what's going on? Have you guys had the dumb, dumb, busy day like me? I mean, today is just like a cute comment. No, I had a super slow day today.|||好吧，我们让观众自己去琢磨吧。你知道我的意思吗？我本想帮你算清楚的，但是。哦，你们这群人。等等，到底怎么回事？你们今天也跟我一样度过了愚蠢又忙碌的一天吗？我是说，今天就像是个可爱的评论。不，我今天过得超级慢。
I did, I had a bunch of. I went to the eye doctor. Oh, check this out. Look at this, I went to the eye doctor. Oh, check this out. Look at this, I went to the eye doctor today. Just my left. Which one was sick? Can you see? Oh yeah, it's still a little...
I did, I had a bunch of. I went to the eye doctor. Oh, check this out. Look at this, I went to the eye doctor. Oh, check this out. Look at this, I went to the eye doctor today. Just my left. Which one was sick? Can you see? Oh yeah, it's still a little...|||是的，我有一堆事。我去看眼科医生了。哦，你看这个。看这个，我去看眼科医生了。哦，你看这个。看这个，我今天去看眼科医生了。只看了左眼。哪只眼睛有病？你能看出来吗？哦，对，还是有点……
One's dilated? Yeah. Two are dilated. So did Scotty have to drive you today? Or did you take risks by yourself? I was like, I'm fine, I'm fine. And I pulled out into traffic. I was like, oh, I don't think I'm fine.
One's dilated? Yeah. Two are dilated. So did Scotty have to drive you today? Or did you take risks by yourself? I was like, I'm fine, I'm fine. And I pulled out into traffic. I was like, oh, I don't think I'm fine.|||一只散瞳了？对。两只都散瞳了。那今天斯科蒂得开车送你吗？还是你自己去冒风险？我当时想，我没事，我没事。然后我把车开进车流里，心想，哦，我觉得我不太好。
Jamie, I thought about you when I got dressed for this because I've been doing a bunch of stuff and I worked out, I did two different kinds of workouts today, but I'm in, it's been a transition, I'm transitioning between different parts of my day and I thought, you know, who's gonna love my look and I'm gonna have to give you the full... Uh-oh, here we go.
Jamie, I thought about you when I got dressed for this because I've been doing a bunch of stuff and I worked out, I did two different kinds of workouts today, but I'm in, it's been a transition, I'm transitioning between different parts of my day and I thought, you know, who's gonna love my look and I'm gonna have to give you the full... Uh-oh, here we go.|||杰米，我今天穿这身衣服的时候想到了你，因为我一直在忙各种事情，我还锻炼了，我今天做了两种不同的锻炼，但我正处于，这是一个过渡期，我正在我一天的不同时段之间转换，我想，你知道的，谁会喜欢我的造型呢，我得把全套的……噢哦，开始了。
Because you're gonna hate it so much. You've already got it on the baggy, the neck, which is nice. He's got the crocs on. He's got white crocs on, guys, with the heel strap. Wow. And then camo shorts. And camo shorts.
Because you're gonna hate it so much. You've already got it on the baggy, the neck, which is nice. He's got the crocs on. He's got white crocs on, guys, with the heel strap. Wow. And then camo shorts. And camo shorts.|||因为你会恨死它的。你已经穿上了宽松的领子，这挺好的。他穿着洞洞鞋。伙计们，他穿着白色的洞洞鞋，还带后跟带。哇。然后是迷彩短裤。还有迷彩短裤。
And then golf socks. So you've got an indoor outfit on today, like me. Or have you been outside? I remember one time. Did anybody see that today? I went outside. I went, nobody saw this, nobody saw this. But I remember one of my favorites was seeing you,
And then golf socks. So you've got an indoor outfit on today, like me. Or have you been outside? I remember one time. Did anybody see that today? I went outside. I went, nobody saw this, nobody saw this. But I remember one of my favorites was seeing you,|||还有高尔夫袜。所以你今天穿了一身室内装，跟我一样。还是你出门了？我记得有一次。今天有人看到那个吗？我出去了。我去了，没人看到这个，没人看到这个。但我记得我最喜欢的其中一次是看到你，
you and I were hanging with Krasinski, this is minimum 15 years ago, and he was wearing some stupid little socks with his Vans, and he just had, and you just look over and you go, laundry day. No, I don't think I said that, because that's the line we've always heard. I think I just said, confident?
you and I were hanging with Krasinski, this is minimum 15 years ago, and he was wearing some stupid little socks with his Vans, and he just had, and you just look over and you go, laundry day. No, I don't think I said that, because that's the line we've always heard. I think I just said, confident?|||你和我跟卡辛斯基一起混，那至少是15年前的事了，他穿着一双蠢兮兮的小短袜搭配万斯鞋，然后他刚好，你转过头去说了一句：“洗衣服的日子吧。”不，我觉得我没这么说，因为那是我们常听到的台词。我想我当时只是说：“很有自信嘛？”
Or is it? Oh, that's true. Oh, that was the other one that you said. No, sorry. Confident, huh? You went confident. No, you didn't say confident, you just went confident. Which is just so shitty.
Or is it? Oh, that's true. Oh, that was the other one that you said. No, sorry. Confident, huh? You went confident. No, you didn't say confident, you just went confident. Which is just so shitty.|||是吗？哦，也对。哦，那是你说的另一句话。不，抱歉。有自信，哈？你用了“有自信”。不，你没说“有自信”，你只是摆出了自信的样子。这真是太逊了。
It's so good. It's so good. It's dumb. But wait, how did, sorry, sorry, guest, we're gonna get right to you, because you're even busier than all three of us combined. How did the white crocs find their way into your closet anyway?
It's so good. It's so good. It's dumb. But wait, how did, sorry, sorry, guest, we're gonna get right to you, because you're even busier than all three of us combined. How did the white crocs find their way into your closet anyway?|||太棒了。太棒了。真蠢。不过等等，怎么会，抱歉，抱歉，嘉宾，我们马上就采访你，因为你比我们三个加起来还要忙。话说白色洞洞鞋是怎么进到你的衣柜里的？
Well, you know what, thanks for the plug. My friends at Dix.com sent me a bunch of stuff. We've seen it, Will. Yeah, they sent me a bunch of stuff. That's nice, didn't they? Bless their hearts, yeah. Instead of money? They sent crocs for me, yeah, that seems fair.
Well, you know what, thanks for the plug. My friends at Dix.com sent me a bunch of stuff. We've seen it, Will. Yeah, they sent me a bunch of stuff. That's nice, didn't they? Bless their hearts, yeah. Instead of money? They sent crocs for me, yeah, that seems fair.|||嗯，你知道吗，谢谢你的广告。我在 Dix.com 的朋友们给我寄了一堆东西。我们看到了，威利。对，他们给我寄了一堆东西。挺不错的，对吧？上帝保佑他们，对。不给钱吗？他们给我寄了洞洞鞋，对，这好像挺公平的。
Did you not get compensated for the commercial? I did, you're looking at them, they're called Crocs. God, those are expensive Crocs. They sent me Crocs for the kids and me, so we all got them, and I've never really worn Crocs, and I'm gonna be honest. They're pretty great. They're really comfortable.
Did you not get compensated for the commercial? I did, you're looking at them, they're called Crocs. God, those are expensive Crocs. They sent me Crocs for the kids and me, so we all got them, and I've never really worn Crocs, and I'm gonna be honest. They're pretty great. They're really comfortable.|||难道你拍广告没有片酬吗？我有啊，你现在正看着呢，它们叫洞洞鞋。天哪，那可是昂贵的洞洞鞋。他们给我和孩子们都寄了洞洞鞋，所以我们都有了，而且我以前从没穿过洞洞鞋，说实话。它们真的挺不错的。它们非常舒服。
They are super comfortable. Really quick, I have a Croc story. Okay. So I was doing promises, promises, and afterwards I met, I have a croc story. So I was doing Promises Promises, and afterwards I met, thank you, thank you, thank you, and afterwards I went out and did the meet and greet that you have to do sometimes when people want to say hi, and there's a very buttoned up family,
They are super comfortable. Really quick, I have a Croc story. Okay. So I was doing promises, promises, and afterwards I met, I have a croc story. So I was doing Promises Promises, and afterwards I met, thank you, thank you, thank you, and afterwards I went out and did the meet and greet that you have to do sometimes when people want to say hi, and there's a very buttoned up family,|||它们超级舒服。快说，我有一个关于洞洞鞋的故事。好的。当时我在演《承诺，承诺》，之后我遇到了，我有一个关于洞洞鞋的故事。当时我在演《承诺，承诺》，之后我遇到了，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，之后我出去参加了见面会，有时候人们想打招呼时你就得去，然后有一个非常保守拘谨的家庭，
and the little boy, he was like nine years old, he had like a suit on with the crocs, and the girl had a little dress on, and after the show you're like fired up, you're doing bits, you're doing bits, you're trying to be funny, you're trying to still entertain them, and so the little girl, she's like, can you sign my show, you're like fired up, you're doing bits, you're doing bits, you're trying to be funny, you're trying to still entertain them. And so the little girl, she's like,
and the little boy, he was like nine years old, he had like a suit on with the crocs, and the girl had a little dress on, and after the show you're like fired up, you're doing bits, you're doing bits, you're trying to be funny, you're trying to still entertain them, and so the little girl, she's like, can you sign my show, you're like fired up, you're doing bits, you're doing bits, you're trying to be funny, you're trying to still entertain them. And so the little girl, she's like,|||那个小男孩大约九岁，穿着西装配洞洞鞋，小女孩穿着一条小裙子，演出结束后你整个人很兴奋，在抖包袱，在抖包袱，你试图表现得有趣，试图继续取悦他们，然后小女孩就说，你能为我的演出……演出结束后你整个人很兴奋，在抖包袱，在抖包袱，你试图表现得有趣，试图继续取悦他们。然后小女孩就说，
can you sign my program? I'm like, sure, what's your name? She's like, Sue. I go, what a tsunami of a performance or some stupid joke. And then I looked at him and he took off his crock and he said, wait, he took off his crock and he said, can you sign this? I go, yeah, wait, shit.
can you sign my program? I'm like, sure, what's your name? She's like, Sue. I go, what a tsunami of a performance or some stupid joke. And then I looked at him and he took off his crock and he said, wait, he took off his crock and he said, can you sign this? I go, yeah, wait, shit.|||你能给我的节目单签个名吗？我说，当然可以，你叫什么名字？她说，苏。我说，这演出简直像海啸一样震撼，或者开了个诸如此类的蠢玩笑。然后我看着他，他脱下他的洞洞鞋说，等等，他脱下他的洞洞鞋说，你能把这个签了名吗？我说，行，等等，靠。
Yeah, he said, how about you sign this for your crock of shit performance? Is that what he said? No. Didn't you tell me one time in a really low moment of your life you wore crocks to a meet and beat? Wait, what's a meet and beat? Oh, sure. Oh, boy. Listeners, can you just call Sean real quick for us?
Yeah, he said, how about you sign this for your crock of shit performance? Is that what he said? No. Didn't you tell me one time in a really low moment of your life you wore crocks to a meet and beat? Wait, what's a meet and beat? Oh, sure. Oh, boy. Listeners, can you just call Sean real quick for us?|||对，他说，那你给你的这场狗屁不如的演出签个名怎么样？他是这么说的吗？没有。你是不是跟我说过，在你人生某个非常低谷的时刻，你穿着洞洞鞋去参加粉丝见面会来着？等等，什么是“粉丝殴打会”？哦，当然。天哪。听众朋友们，你们能帮我们马上给肖恩打个电话吗？
Oh, a meet and beat. Okay, I did the math. Okay, guys, do you like football? Hey, Willie, Sean, do you like football? Yeah, I actually really do. Do you like golf? Do you like horse racing? Do you like car racing? Do you like basketball?
Oh, a meet and beat. Okay, I did the math. Okay, guys, do you like football? Hey, Willie, Sean, do you like football? Yeah, I actually really do. Do you like golf? Do you like horse racing? Do you like car racing? Do you like basketball?|||哦，粉丝见面会。好吧，我懂了。好了，伙计们，你们喜欢橄榄球吗？嘿，威利，肖恩，你们喜欢橄榄球吗？对，我其实真的很喜欢。你们喜欢高尔夫吗？你们喜欢赛马吗？你们喜欢赛车吗？你们喜欢篮球吗？
Do you like the Olympics? Yeah. Our guest today is the guy that's been holding your hand for about 35 years through some of the most exciting live television and personal excellence ever. He is as casual and comforting as he is knowledgeable and anxiety inducing. He's your favorite house guest,
Do you like the Olympics? Yeah. Our guest today is the guy that's been holding your hand for about 35 years through some of the most exciting live television and personal excellence ever. He is as casual and comforting as he is knowledgeable and anxiety inducing. He's your favorite house guest,|||你们喜欢奥运会吗？对。我们今天的嘉宾陪伴了大家大约35年，带大家度过了许多最激动人心的现场直播和展现个人卓越的时刻。他既随和又令人安心，同时也博学多才且能制造焦虑。他是你最喜欢的做客嘉宾，
but he's got no idea where you live, guys. He knows all the things about sports, but is not an athlete. He is as familiar as a family member, but you don't know a thing about him until now. Will, Sean, listeners, please welcome the star of the highest rated television show, 13 years running and the host of the upcoming Summer Olympics in Paris, the one and only Mr. Mike Turrico. Mike Turrico.
but he's got no idea where you live, guys. He knows all the things about sports, but is not an athlete. He is as familiar as a family member, but you don't know a thing about him until now. Will, Sean, listeners, please welcome the star of the highest rated television show, 13 years running and the host of the upcoming Summer Olympics in Paris, the one and only Mr. Mike Turrico. Mike Turrico.|||但他根本不知道你们住在哪里，伙计们。他通晓体育界的一切，却不是一名运动员。他熟悉得就像家庭成员一样，但在今天之前你对他的了解一无所知。威利、肖恩、各位听众，请欢迎连续13年收视率最高的电视节目之星、即将到来的巴黎夏季奥运会主持人，独一无二的迈克·图里科先生。迈克·图里科。
Oh wow. Big reveal. There I am. I mean, is that an intro? God, I was trying to write that down. I want to repeat that Jason's busy day he wrote that intro yeah Welcome Mike. It is very good to have you here I am a listener, and it's it's an honor to be on although. I'm nervous as hell Please you don't have time to listen to dumbass podcasters. Maybe you forget you didn't catch the part where I'm wearing crotch Mike
Oh wow. Big reveal. There I am. I mean, is that an intro? God, I was trying to write that down. I want to repeat that Jason's busy day he wrote that intro yeah Welcome Mike. It is very good to have you here I am a listener, and it's it's an honor to be on although. I'm nervous as hell Please you don't have time to listen to dumbass podcasters. Maybe you forget you didn't catch the part where I'm wearing crotch Mike|||哦，哇。隆重登场。我来了。我的天，这算是一段开场白吗？天哪，我刚才正试图把它记下来呢。我想重复一下，那是杰森在百忙之中写的开场白，对。欢迎你，迈克。很高兴你能来到这里。我是你们的节目听众，能上这个节目是我的荣幸，尽管我紧张得要死。求你了，你哪有时间去听那些蠢货播客主的话。也许你忘了，你没注意到我刚才说我穿着洞洞鞋呢，迈克。
dumbass podcast. We're losers. Maybe you didn't catch the part where I'm wearing crotch, Mike. I did. I did. So. Now, when do you squeak in the time to listen to anything? Like on planes, I'll bet. Yeah, on planes, on a walk.
dumbass podcast. We're losers. Maybe you didn't catch the part where I'm wearing crotch, Mike. I did. I did. So. Now, when do you squeak in the time to listen to anything? Like on planes, I'll bet. Yeah, on planes, on a walk.|||蠢货播客。我们都是失败者。也许你没听到我刚才说我穿着洞洞鞋那段吧，迈克。我听到了。我听到了。所以。话说回来，你平时都是什么时候挤出时间来听东西的？比如在飞机上，我敢打赌。对，在飞机上，在散步的时候。
I'm like a 1.75 podcast listener. I need to get them over quick, you know? So I try to squeeze them in. So you might go like a horse racing or auto racing around the events. And then, like, I need a little bit of a change. So actually one day one of our PR guys said,
I'm like a 1.75 podcast listener. I need to get them over quick, you know? So I try to squeeze them in. So you might go like a horse racing or auto racing around the events. And then, like, I need a little bit of a change. So actually one day one of our PR guys said,|||我大概算是一个1.75倍速的播客听众吧。我得快点听完，你知道吗？所以我尽量抽空听。所以你可能会去现场看赛马或赛车比赛。然后，比如说，我需要换换口味。所以其实有一天我们公关部门的一个人说，
you know, look at the top 10 podcasts in America. And I saw this one, I said, this is the only one that really appeals to me. So I'm not an every week guy, but I'm here every once in a while. Well, listen, there's a little something for everybody on this dumb show. Yes, it is.
you know, look at the top 10 podcasts in America. And I saw this one, I said, this is the only one that really appeals to me. So I'm not an every week guy, but I'm here every once in a while. Well, listen, there's a little something for everybody on this dumb show. Yes, it is.|||你知道的，看看美国排名前十的播客。我看到了这个节目，我说，这是唯一真正吸引我的节目。所以我不是每期都听的忠实粉丝，但我偶尔会来听听。好吧，听着，在这个愚蠢的节目里，每个人都能找到适合自己的东西。确实如此。
You, however, are right up my alley, mister. So let's just get into it, Mike. Let's start from the beginning. Let's start from the very beginning. So your dad's driving your mom to the hospital, right? She's in, she's in. All right, so let's, well where did it, were you an athlete, are you an athlete?
You, however, are right up my alley, mister. So let's just get into it, Mike. Let's start from the beginning. Let's start from the very beginning. So your dad's driving your mom to the hospital, right? She's in, she's in. All right, so let's, well where did it, were you an athlete, are you an athlete?|||不过你嘛，先生，完全对我的胃口。所以我们直接切入正题吧，迈克。让我们从头说起。从最初开始说起。所以你爸爸开车载着你妈妈去医院，对吧？她当时在，她正在。好吧，那么让我们，呃，那是怎么回事，你以前是个运动员吗，你是个运动员吗？
I worked that into the intro there because it kind of rolled nice, but I'll bet you're a bit of an athlete, right? No, no. No? You were right. So in my family, we have two kids. My wife played basketball at Syracuse.
I worked that into the intro there because it kind of rolled nice, but I'll bet you're a bit of an athlete, right? No, no. No? You were right. So in my family, we have two kids. My wife played basketball at Syracuse.|||我把那句话塞进开场白里是因为听起来挺顺的，但我敢打赌你多少算个运动员吧？不，不。不是吗？你说得对。在我的家庭里，我们有两个孩子。我妻子曾在锡拉丘兹大学打过篮球。
So we have a dog. And you went to Syracuse, that's where you guys met? Yeah, that's where we met. So we have a dogs. There are five of us in the house. I'm the fifth athlete in the house. You know, I play golf, it's not pretty. I love it. I feel like I'm this close. I'm the king of the range. I've won more titles on the range than maybe any golfer alive. And I feel really good in the short game area.
So we have a dog. And you went to Syracuse, that's where you guys met? Yeah, that's where we met. So we have a dogs. There are five of us in the house. I'm the fifth athlete in the house. You know, I play golf, it's not pretty. I love it. I feel like I'm this close. I'm the king of the range. I've won more titles on the range than maybe any golfer alive. And I feel really good in the short game area.|||所以我们有一条狗。你去了锡拉丘兹大学，你们是在那里认识的？是的，我们在那里认识的。所以我们有一条狗。家里总共有五口人。我是家里排名第五的运动员。你知道的，我打高尔夫球，姿势不太好看。我很喜欢。我觉得我就差这么一点了。我是练习场之王。我在练习场上赢得的冠军头衔可能比任何在世的高尔夫球手都要多。而且我觉得自己在短杆区域表现非常好。
And then for some stupid reason it doesn't translate So I got how bad a golfer are you let me guess I'm a 15. I was gonna put you at a 10 Yeah, I was a coven. I was 10.2. Yeah, I was feeling pretty good about life, and I said here we go We're going we're gonna get to single digits life's gonna be good and that hasn't happened you so wait You got your index down to a 10 too? I did during COVID. I was playing every day and I kinda knew what I was doing. It was socially distant, yeah.
And then for some stupid reason it doesn't translate So I got how bad a golfer are you let me guess I'm a 15. I was gonna put you at a 10 Yeah, I was a coven. I was 10.2. Yeah, I was feeling pretty good about life, and I said here we go We're going we're gonna get to single digits life's gonna be good and that hasn't happened you so wait You got your index down to a 10 too? I did during COVID. I was playing every day and I kinda knew what I was doing. It was socially distant, yeah.|||然后出于某种愚蠢的原因，它就是转化不到实际战绩上。所以我想问你高尔夫打得有多烂？让我猜猜，我是15差点。我本来想给你评个10差点。对，我以前是，我是10.2差。对，我当时对生活感觉挺好的，我说太棒了，我们要打进个位数了，生活会很美好的，然而并没有发生。等等，你把差点降到了10.2？我在新冠疫情期间做到了。我当时每天都在打，而且我大概知道自己在干什么。那是保持社交距离的活动，对。
That's what got me back into golf. That's when we started playing again was during COVID. We hadn't played for years, JB and I. Yeah, we started playing and then it just, and then JB went absolutely mental. Because I have addiction issues. Well, he does and it was crazy and then his wife is really mad at golf and blah, blah, blah and. Well, he does, and it was crazy. And then his wife is really mad at golf and blah, blah, blah,
That's what got me back into golf. That's when we started playing again was during COVID. We hadn't played for years, JB and I. Yeah, we started playing and then it just, and then JB went absolutely mental. Because I have addiction issues. Well, he does and it was crazy and then his wife is really mad at golf and blah, blah, blah and. Well, he does, and it was crazy. And then his wife is really mad at golf and blah, blah, blah,|||就是那次让我重新开始打高尔夫。那就是我们重新开始打球的时候，在疫情期间。我和JB已经好几年没打球了。对，我们开始打球，然后，然后JB就彻底疯了。因为我有成瘾问题。嗯，他确实有，而且太疯狂了，然后他老婆对高尔夫超级生气，巴拉巴拉的。嗯，他确实有，而且太疯狂了。然后他老婆对高尔夫超级生气，巴拉巴拉的，
and I said, you know, the fix to it is don't go mental, right? Just do it like, don't do it every day. But he couldn't hear me because he was watching swing videos. I'm obsessive. But now that I'm working, I put them down for nine months. I won't even touch my clubs. So when you go back, will you be good? I will be terrible and I will stay out of the money games because I'll still be stuck with my old index But here's what's so weird. So so this is it's funny that JB so I said to JB
and I said, you know, the fix to it is don't go mental, right? Just do it like, don't do it every day. But he couldn't hear me because he was watching swing videos. I'm obsessive. But now that I'm working, I put them down for nine months. I won't even touch my clubs. So when you go back, will you be good? I will be terrible and I will stay out of the money games because I'll still be stuck with my old index But here's what's so weird. So so this is it's funny that JB so I said to JB|||我说，你知道吗，解决的办法就是别走火入魔，对吧？只要像这样，别每天都打。但他根本听不进去，因为他一直在看挥杆视频。我有强迫症倾向。但现在因为要工作，我把球杆放下九个月了。我连球杆都不会碰一下。所以当你重新开始时，你会打得很好吗？我会打得很烂，而且我会远离那些赌钱的比赛，因为我还是会被困在我以前的差点上。但奇怪的地方就在这里。所以，所以这很有趣，JB，所以我对JB说，
Sunday we all saw each other for dinner He'd been in New York for a couple months and I said why don't you know? Yes, then I said why don't you come to the range? With me just cuz you're here this week. don't you come to the range with me? Just because you're here this week, just come to the range over at where we play. Can't even be around it. He's like, no, I can't do it until October. It's a trigger, trigger situation.
Sunday we all saw each other for dinner He'd been in New York for a couple months and I said why don't you know? Yes, then I said why don't you come to the range? With me just cuz you're here this week. don't you come to the range with me? Just because you're here this week, just come to the range over at where we play. Can't even be around it. He's like, no, I can't do it until October. It's a trigger, trigger situation.|||周日我们聚在一起吃晚饭，他在纽约呆了几个月，我说你怎么不？对，然后我说你为什么不来练习场？跟我一起去，就因为你这周在这儿。你为什么不跟我一起去练习场？就因为你这周在这儿，去我们常去的那家练习场看看。他连靠近都不行。他说，不行，我直到十月之前都不能碰。这会触发心瘾，是个诱发情况。
Well, it's just about moderation, my friend. Yeah, I'm not good at five. I need every, a 10 or a zero. That's my problem. Wouldn't you find it as a release? Just get away for a little bit, stop your mind. That's what I find. There you go.
Well, it's just about moderation, my friend. Yeah, I'm not good at five. I need every, a 10 or a zero. That's my problem. Wouldn't you find it as a release? Just get away for a little bit, stop your mind. That's what I find. There you go.|||好吧，这全在于适度，我的朋友。对，我不擅长做到适可而止。我需要么是10，么是0。这就是我的问题。难道你不觉得这是一种解脱吗？稍微远离一下，让你的大脑停下来。我是这么觉得的。就是这样。
Yeah, it's true, but then that means I've gotta be kind of indifferent as to how I'm playing and I gotta care, you know? I mean, you know what I'm talking about. You don't call me to see the way I'm gonna bring it right back to you. You don't phone in your work there. You make it seem very casual,
Yeah, it's true, but then that means I've gotta be kind of indifferent as to how I'm playing and I gotta care, you know? I mean, you know what I'm talking about. You don't call me to see the way I'm gonna bring it right back to you. You don't phone in your work there. You make it seem very casual,|||是的，确实如此，但那就意味着我对自己的表现得表现得有点漠不关心，而我又必须在乎，你知道吗？我的意思是，你知道我在说什么。你不会打电话来看着我怎么把话题又绕回你身上。你在工作上可从不敷衍。你把它表现得非常随性，
but it takes a tremendous amount of preparation, I would imagine, especially just in switching sports, but then having to know all the specific players and the relevance of that game per the rivalries between those teams and where it sits in the season and all of that stuff is just like, talk to us about your preparation, about your team. I'm sure you've got people that you're reliant on
but it takes a tremendous amount of preparation, I would imagine, especially just in switching sports, but then having to know all the specific players and the relevance of that game per the rivalries between those teams and where it sits in the season and all of that stuff is just like, talk to us about your preparation, about your team. I'm sure you've got people that you're reliant on|||但我可以想象，这需要进行大量的准备工作，特别是光是在切换不同的运动项目上，还要了解所有具体的运动员、每场比赛对于两队之间宿敌关系的重要性、它在赛季中所处的位置等等诸如此类的事情，简直就像是——跟我们聊聊你的准备工作，还有你的团队。我确信你有一些非常依赖的人，
that are incredible. You're right, you nailed it. I'm paranoid that one day I'm gonna wake up and we'll have Katie Ledecky riding one of the horses in the Kentucky Derby. You know what I'm saying? Exactly. Circuits of cross, no, no, no, stop, right?
that are incredible. You're right, you nailed it. I'm paranoid that one day I'm gonna wake up and we'll have Katie Ledecky riding one of the horses in the Kentucky Derby. You know what I'm saying? Exactly. Circuits of cross, no, no, no, stop, right?|||他们都非常了不起。你说得对，一针见血。我有种被害妄想，总觉得有一天醒来，我们会看到凯蒂·莱德基在肯塔基德比中骑着一匹马。你知道我在说什么吗？没错。越野赛道，不，不，不，停，对吧？
We have unbelievable research teams. The story of the Olympics on TV in America. Yeah. It has, the research department for the Olympics has been kind of the training ground for a lot of executives in TV. Wow. Over like 30, 40 years.
We have unbelievable research teams. The story of the Olympics on TV in America. Yeah. It has, the research department for the Olympics has been kind of the training ground for a lot of executives in TV. Wow. Over like 30, 40 years.|||我们拥有令人难以置信的研究团队。奥运会在美国电视上的转播历史。是的。奥运会的研究部门可以说是电视界许多高管的训练营。哇。大约历经了30、40年。
So a bunch of the people who were Olympic researchers in the 70s and 80s and 90s now run sports divisions at CBS and at NBC. Really? They're super smart people and they give you more than you can read and you just got to figure out how to shorten the stack and how to keep it organized. I'm not going to learn the rules for the 30 sports and all the names of the 10,000 athletes
So a bunch of the people who were Olympic researchers in the 70s and 80s and 90s now run sports divisions at CBS and at NBC. Really? They're super smart people and they give you more than you can read and you just got to figure out how to shorten the stack and how to keep it organized. I'm not going to learn the rules for the 30 sports and all the names of the 10,000 athletes|||所以，当年在70、80、90年代担任奥运会研究员的一批人，现在正在CBS和NBC掌管体育部门。真的吗？他们都是超级聪明的人，他们给你的资料多得你根本读不完，你只需要找出如何精简这些资料堆并保持条理的方法。我不可能去学完30项运动的规则以及1万名运动员的所有名字，
for the Summer Olympics. but that's my job Who deserves the the the accolades for that was it was it rune Arledge? Yeah in the day yeah, yeah, do it going back to when ABC had the Olympics and Remember the wide world of sports when it started it was okay. Yes It was the ski jumper falling off the side the best. Yeah I mean, not for him, but the best for us. The guy's name is Venko Bogatai. That was his name. I sat at the top of that speed at that ski jump in Austria once. You know, there's a big graveyard at the bottom of it.
for the Summer Olympics. but that's my job Who deserves the the the accolades for that was it was it rune Arledge? Yeah in the day yeah, yeah, do it going back to when ABC had the Olympics and Remember the wide world of sports when it started it was okay. Yes It was the ski jumper falling off the side the best. Yeah I mean, not for him, but the best for us. The guy's name is Venko Bogatai. That was his name. I sat at the top of that speed at that ski jump in Austria once. You know, there's a big graveyard at the bottom of it.|||为了夏季奥运会。但这就是我的工作。谁应该为此获得赞誉？是鲁恩·阿尔雷奇吗？是的，在当年，是的，是的，回到ABC转播奥运会的那个时代，还记得《世界体育广角镜》刚开播的时候吗，还挺不错的。是的。就是那个滑雪跳投运动员从边上摔下来的画面，太棒了。是的，我是说，对他来说可不算，但对我们来说是最棒的。那家伙的名字叫文科·博加塔伊。那就是他的名字。我曾经坐在奥地利那个滑雪跳台的速度顶端。你知道的，它底部有一个巨大的墓地。
It's like that's all you can see from the top of that ski jump is just this massive graveyard. It explains why he took the exit ramp to the left. Yeah, exactly. He got subtracted. Yeah, but it was the thrill of victory, the agony of defeat, but it was up close and personal. That was their tagline for the profiles. And one of the great executives in the history of television, not just sports television, Dick Embersol, because he was involved with Lorne Michaels
It's like that's all you can see from the top of that ski jump is just this massive graveyard. It explains why he took the exit ramp to the left. Yeah, exactly. He got subtracted. Yeah, but it was the thrill of victory, the agony of defeat, but it was up close and personal. That was their tagline for the profiles. And one of the great executives in the history of television, not just sports television, Dick Embersol, because he was involved with Lorne Michaels|||从那个滑雪跳台的顶端望过去，你只能看到这片巨大的墓地。这就解释了为什么他会往左边驶出减速坡道。是的，没错。他被“减掉”了。对，但这就是胜利的喜悦、失败的痛苦，而且它是那么的近距离和具有个人色彩。那是他们人物特写的标语。电视史上最伟大的高管之一，不仅仅是体育电视，迪克·埃伯索尔，因为他曾与洛恩·迈尔斯一起参与过
with Saturday Night Live and all that stuff. Dick really brought, he was working with Rune at ABC as a researcher in the 70s and he brought that sensibility and that storytelling to NBC way before I got there when NBC got the Olympics. And that has kind of defined our division since Dick was there and all the people who learned from him who are now in charge. Tell a story. Make me care about the people.
with Saturday Night Live and all that stuff. Dick really brought, he was working with Rune at ABC as a researcher in the 70s and he brought that sensibility and that storytelling to NBC way before I got there when NBC got the Olympics. And that has kind of defined our division since Dick was there and all the people who learned from him who are now in charge. Tell a story. Make me care about the people.|||《周六夜现场》之类的工作。迪克确实把——他在70年代作为研究员在ABC与鲁恩共事过——那种敏锐度和讲故事的能力带到了NBC，那远在我来到NBC获得奥运会转播权之前。自从迪克在那里工作以来，以及所有向他学习并现在掌权的人，这种风格基本上定义了我们部门。讲一个故事。让我关心这些人物。
It's my favorite part of the Olympics because these are people that are not making money in sports yet, they have to be an amateur to be. Well, that's kind of changed a little bit. Yeah, it's some sports, but for the most part, it is, you are tuning in to see these very, sort of the people that you live next door to that are having these two minutes, this opportunity for personal excellence
It's my favorite part of the Olympics because these are people that are not making money in sports yet, they have to be an amateur to be. Well, that's kind of changed a little bit. Yeah, it's some sports, but for the most part, it is, you are tuning in to see these very, sort of the people that you live next door to that are having these two minutes, this opportunity for personal excellence|||这是我最喜欢的奥运会部分，因为这些人目前还无法通过体育赚钱，他们必须是以业余身份参赛。嗯，现在情况稍微有点变化了。是的，某些项目是这样，但在大多数情况下，你收看节目是为了看到这些非常……有点像住在你隔壁的邻居，他们拥有这短短两分钟的机会，这个展现个人卓越的机会，
that they have been training for for 10, 15 years. And are they gonna be overwhelmed by the moment, by the media, by the stress, or are they gonna soar to new heights because they're charged up? And I just met them with this five minute piece that started way back then and I think was Rune Oroge's idea, right?
that they have been training for for 10, 15 years. And are they gonna be overwhelmed by the moment, by the media, by the stress, or are they gonna soar to new heights because they're charged up? And I just met them with this five minute piece that started way back then and I think was Rune Oroge's idea, right?|||他们为此训练了10年、15年。他们会被当时的氛围、媒体和压力压垮吗，还是会因为充满斗志而飞向新的高度？我通过这个五分钟的短片与他们相遇，这个传统很久以前就开始了，我想这是鲁恩·阿尔雷奇的主意，对吧？
Like get to know the athlete and then as soon as you're done with that story, you cut right to them on the starting line. And it's just like, oh my God. Well, cause now you're invested. Yeah, and you guys are storytellers in your own way. So you get it. Here's the difference now.
Like get to know the athlete and then as soon as you're done with that story, you cut right to them on the starting line. And it's just like, oh my God. Well, cause now you're invested. Yeah, and you guys are storytellers in your own way. So you get it. Here's the difference now.|||比如先去了解这位运动员，一旦那个故事讲完，镜头立刻切到他们在起跑线上的画面。那种感觉简直是，哦天哪。嗯，因为现在你已经投入其中了。对，你们用各自的方式讲故事。所以你们懂的。现在的区别在于：
You don't have five minutes. People aren't going to sit around for your story in five minutes. So our adjustment has become make it bite-size, make you care about somebody, and then show me their event, or even the night before, hey, here's this athlete's story, and tomorrow night they go for gold. Right, yeah, you started a little bit early. Well, you had Sean at bite-size, by the way. I'm in, I just showed up.
You don't have five minutes. People aren't going to sit around for your story in five minutes. So our adjustment has become make it bite-size, make you care about somebody, and then show me their event, or even the night before, hey, here's this athlete's story, and tomorrow night they go for gold. Right, yeah, you started a little bit early. Well, you had Sean at bite-size, by the way. I'm in, I just showed up.|||你们没有五分钟的时间。人们不会坐下来花五分钟听你讲故事。所以我们的调整变成了：把它做成碎片化，让你关心某个人，然后向我展示他们的比赛，甚至在前一天晚上就说，嘿，这是这位运动员的故事，明天晚上他们将向金牌发起冲击。对，是的，你们开始得有点早。顺便说一句，你们找肖恩来做这种“碎片化”的内容最合适不过了。我加入啦，我刚到。
You started, even at the opening ceremonies, you guys started by sort of just dropping little breadcrumbs on Uncertain. No, it's really cool. So, Mike, let's go back a little bit, because obviously you're at the top of the game. As Jason pointed out, Sunday Night Football is the number one show on TV, right? Yes.
You started, even at the opening ceremonies, you guys started by sort of just dropping little breadcrumbs on Uncertain. No, it's really cool. So, Mike, let's go back a little bit, because obviously you're at the top of the game. As Jason pointed out, Sunday Night Football is the number one show on TV, right? Yes.|||你们甚至在开幕式上就开始了，你们一开始只是在《不确定》节目中抛出一些小面包屑。不，这真的很酷。所以，迈克，让我们稍微回顾一下，因为显然你正处于行业巅峰。正如杰森所指出的，“周日橄榄球之夜”是电视上收视率第一的节目，对吧？是的。
Oh, yeah. And you've been doing this at the top. What is that moment? You're Mike Tirico at Syracuse. How do you become sports commentator, play-by-play, sports host of the biggest? What is that thing? Are you calling games when you're in your bedroom when you're 11 little bit just drove down
Oh, yeah. And you've been doing this at the top. What is that moment? You're Mike Tirico at Syracuse. How do you become sports commentator, play-by-play, sports host of the biggest? What is that thing? Are you calling games when you're in your bedroom when you're 11 little bit just drove down|||哦，是的。而且你一直处于这个行业的巅峰。那是怎样的一个时刻？你是身在锡拉丘兹大学的迈克·图里科。你是如何成为体育评论员、实况转播员、最大牌的体育主持人的？那是个怎样的过程？你11岁在卧室里的时候就开始对着比赛解说了一点点，刚刚开着车
this really Bristol and just like circled the building a couple of times right throw a headshot window no no seriously when I was a little kid you asked my mom this is what I wanted to do I wanted to be a sportscaster being so cool a little kid I'm really I am 55 years later living my dream still every day. I do love work. Where was that? Queens. Queens, New York. So when I grew up, I was listening to Marv Albert broadcast. And the Rangers and work at NBC. Garbage time. Extensive garbage time. Marv did everything, right? He did boxing, football, the local news, the Rangers, the Knicks. And so I always thought, you know what? Do everything. Just figure out a way
this really Bristol and just like circled the building a couple of times right throw a headshot window no no seriously when I was a little kid you asked my mom this is what I wanted to do I wanted to be a sportscaster being so cool a little kid I'm really I am 55 years later living my dream still every day. I do love work. Where was that? Queens. Queens, New York. So when I grew up, I was listening to Marv Albert broadcast. And the Rangers and work at NBC. Garbage time. Extensive garbage time. Marv did everything, right? He did boxing, football, the local news, the Rangers, the Knicks. And so I always thought, you know what? Do everything. Just figure out a way|||穿过真正的布里斯托尔，然后绕着那栋建筑转了好几圈，对吧，扔进一个大头照窗户，不，不，说真的，当我还是个小孩子的时候，你问我妈妈，这就是我想做的事情，我想成为一名体育播报员，这对于一个小孩子来说太酷了，真的，55年后的今天，我每天依然在过着我的梦想生活。我是真的很热爱工作。那是哪里？皇后区。纽约皇后区。所以当我长大后，我一直在听马尔夫·阿尔伯特的转播。还有流浪者队，并在NBC工作。垃圾时间。大量的垃圾时间。马尔夫什么都做，对吧？他播报拳击、橄榄球、地方新闻、流浪者队、尼克斯队。所以我总是想，你知道吗？什么都做。只要想办法
to become proficient at every sport that you can be invited to do. And Jim McKay, who somebody mentioned before, Jim McKay was the same thing. And those two guys were the models for me to, hey, go figure it out. Went to college at Syracuse, interned at a TV station. They went through three weekend sportscasters in seven weeks. The GM said I'm gonna hire somebody young and cheap. I was interning there.
to become proficient at every sport that you can be invited to do. And Jim McKay, who somebody mentioned before, Jim McKay was the same thing. And those two guys were the models for me to, hey, go figure it out. Went to college at Syracuse, interned at a TV station. They went through three weekend sportscasters in seven weeks. The GM said I'm gonna hire somebody young and cheap. I was interning there.|||让自己精通你被邀请解说的每一项运动。还有吉姆·麦凯，刚才有人提到过他，吉姆·麦凯也是这样。这两个人就是我的榜样，激励我去探索、去摸索。我在锡拉丘兹大学上大学，在一家电视台实习。他们在七周内换了三个周末体育播报员。总经理说我要雇一个年轻又便宜的人。当时我在那里实习。
I was young and I was cheap. And I got a tryout. I got a tryout on the air for six weeks. Got hired after four weeks. Spent four years there and then got to ESPN in 91, was there for 25 years and now eight years at NBC. So hang on, sorry, I just could you gloss over ESPN. So you go to ESPN and that's where a lot of us
I was young and I was cheap. And I got a tryout. I got a tryout on the air for six weeks. Got hired after four weeks. Spent four years there and then got to ESPN in 91, was there for 25 years and now eight years at NBC. So hang on, sorry, I just could you gloss over ESPN. So you go to ESPN and that's where a lot of us|||我很年轻，也很便宜。我得到了一个试镜机会。我在节目中试镜了六周。四周后就被录用了。在那里呆了四年，然后在1991年去了ESPN，在那里呆了25年，现在在NBC呆了8年。等等，抱歉，我只想问你能简略带过ESPN吗。所以你去了ESPN，那是我们许多人
got to know you first on a national level obviously. And as a- And they saw you on the local station there in Syracuse, I'm assuming? There was somebody who actually is still a friend, and we work in a different capacity now, who saw me doing local TV and was an executive at ESPN. And they told me, send a tape in a year. I sent the tape in 10 months, got hired a few months later, and did Sports Center.
got to know you first on a national level obviously. And as a- And they saw you on the local station there in Syracuse, I'm assuming? There was somebody who actually is still a friend, and we work in a different capacity now, who saw me doing local TV and was an executive at ESPN. And they told me, send a tape in a year. I sent the tape in 10 months, got hired a few months later, and did Sports Center.|||第一次在全国范围内认识你的地方，显然。作为——我猜他们是在锡拉丘兹当地电视台看到你的吧？有一个人——其实他现在还是我的朋友，我们现在以不同的身份共事——他在ESPN担任高管时看到了我主持地方电视节目。他告诉我，一年后寄一盘磁带过来。我在10个月后寄出了磁带，几个月后就被录用了，开始主持《体育中心》。
I was there in the salad days. Yes. Sports Center. I was with in the salad days. The Sports Center, I was with Chris Myers, who works at Fox now. The weekends were Carl Ravitch and Linda Cohn, who are still there at ESPN all these years later. And the main group was Dan Patrick and Keith Olbermann and Bob Lee and Charlie Steiner, Robin Roberts, Gary Miller, we just had this group that is still,
I was there in the salad days. Yes. Sports Center. I was with Chris Myers, who works at Fox now. The weekends were Carl Ravitch and Linda Cohn, who are still there at ESPN all these years later. And the main group was Dan Patrick and Keith Olbermann and Bob Lee and Charlie Steiner, Robin Roberts, Gary Miller, we just had this group that is still,|||我在那里的黄金时期度过了那段时光。是的。《体育中心》。我和现在在福克斯工作的克里斯·迈尔斯在一起。周末的主持人是卡尔·拉维奇和琳达·科恩，时隔多年他们依然留在ESPN。核心团队有丹·帕特里克、基斯·奥尔伯曼、鲍勃·李、查理·施泰纳、罗宾·罗伯茨、加里·米勒，我们这个团队直到今天，
for the most part, all on TV doing national sports almost 25, 30 years later. I love that. That was like, you guys were like the Beatles of sportscasters. That was like the first, like that generation, you guys were, you set, because nobody was doing it, nobody had done it the way you guys were doing it before,
for the most part, all on TV doing national sports almost 25, 30 years later. I love that. That was like, you guys were like the Beatles of sportscasters. That was like the first, like that generation, you guys were, you set, because nobody was doing it, nobody had done it the way you guys were doing it before,|||大部分人依然在电视上播报全国体育赛事，差不多25、30年过去了。我太喜欢这样了。那感觉就像，你们简直就是体育播报员里的甲壳虫乐队。那是第一代，就像那个时代一样，你们奠定了基础，因为以前没有人这样做过，没有人像你们那样做过，
and you set that tone, and everybody after that was trying to replicate that, really. Yeah. And we will be right back. Hey smart list listener, we get support from Mint Mobile. You know when you discover a new binge-worthy show or a song that you play on repeat and you have to share with your friends so they can experience just how awesome it is? That's kind of what it feels like when you discover that Mint Mobile offers premium wireless for $15 a month. When you purchase a three-month plan, it's
and you set that tone, and everybody after that was trying to replicate that, really. Yeah. And we will be right back. Hey smart list listener, we get support from Mint Mobile. You know when you discover a new binge-worthy show or a song that you play on repeat and you have to share with your friends so they can experience just how awesome it is? That's kind of what it feels like when you discover that Mint Mobile offers premium wireless for $15 a month. When you purchase a three-month plan, it's|||你们定下了那种基调，在那之后的每个人都在试图复制这种风格，真的。是的。我们马上回来。嘿，Smartless 的听众们，我们得到了 Mint Mobile 的赞助支持。你知道当你发现一部让人欲罢不能的新剧，或者一首单曲循环的歌时，你总会忍不住跟朋友分享，让他们也感受一下它有多棒吗？当你发现 Mint Mobile 提供每月 15 美元的高端无线服务时，差不多就是这种感觉。当你购买三个月的套餐时，
such an awesome deal. There's no way you can keep it to yourself. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you and your squad with premium wireless plans starting at $15 a month. All plans come with high-speed data and unlimited talk and text delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash smartless. That's mintmobile.com slash smartless. Cut your wireless bill to $15 a month at mintmobile.com slash smartless. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month.
such an awesome deal. There's no way you can keep it to yourself. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you and your squad with premium wireless plans starting at $15 a month. All plans come with high-speed data and unlimited talk and text delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash smartless. That's mintmobile.com slash smartless. Cut your wireless bill to $15 a month at mintmobile.com slash smartless. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month.|||这优惠简直太棒了。你绝对忍不住想独享。Mint Mobile 来拯救你和你的小伙伴了，高端无线套餐只需每月 15 美元起。所有套餐均包含高速流量以及在全美最大的 5G 网络上提供的无限通话和短信。使用你自己的手机搭配任何 Mint Mobile 套餐，并带上你的手机号码以及所有现有联系人。要获得此新客户优惠以及每月仅需 15 美元的新 3 个月高端无线套餐，请访问 mintmobile.com slash smartless。即 mintmobile.com slash smartless。访问 mintmobile.com slash smartless，将你的话费削减至每月 15 美元。需预付 45 美元，相当于每月 15 美元。
New customers on first 3-month plan only. Speed slower above 40 gigabytes on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees, and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. Upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month. and but it was hot, hot, hot. And we were outside all the time and I was just sweating and sweating. I put sunscreen on. I just kept sweating and losing all that water and like sweating and sweating, not only because of the sun, just because there was 26 people in one house, but it was super fun. And I just thought, you know what,
New customers on first 3-month plan only. Speed slower above 40 gigabytes on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees, and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. Upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month. and but it was hot, hot, hot. And we were outside all the time and I was just sweating and sweating. I put sunscreen on. I just kept sweating and losing all that water and like sweating and sweating, not only because of the sun, just because there was 26 people in one house, but it was super fun. And I just thought, you know what,|||仅限首次购买 3 个月套餐的新客户。无限流量套餐使用超过 40GB 后网速会变慢。需缴纳额外的税费、手续费并受其他限制条件约束。详情请参阅 Mint Mobile。需预付相当于每月 15 美元的费用。但那里天气热得要命。我们一直在室外，我一直在不停地出汗。我涂了防晒霜。我还是不停地出汗，流失了大量水分，一直在出汗，不仅是因为太阳大，还因为一栋房子里住了26个人，但真的超级好玩。我当时就想，你知道吗，
before I left, I thought enough to pack Liquid IV with me. And it's such great news because they have all those nostalgic flavors. Now that bring you back to you know those free-spirited summers with Liquid IV. Like their returning fan favorite, hydration multiplier cotton candy. Yeah that's a flavor. A technicolor dreamscape of hydration. No fluff, all functional benefits with a sweet vanilla taste. Just one stick of Liquid IV hydrates you better than water alone with triple the electrolytes of the top sports drink plus eight essential vitamins and nutrients.
before I left, I thought enough to pack Liquid IV with me. And it's such great news because they have all those nostalgic flavors. Now that bring you back to you know those free-spirited summers with Liquid IV. Like their returning fan favorite, hydration multiplier cotton candy. Yeah that's a flavor. A technicolor dreamscape of hydration. No fluff, all functional benefits with a sweet vanilla taste. Just one stick of Liquid IV hydrates you better than water alone with triple the electrolytes of the top sports drink plus eight essential vitamins and nutrients.|||在我离开之前，我很明智地带上了 Liquid IV。这真是个好消息，因为他们有各种充满怀旧情调的口味。现在它们能带你回到，你知道的，充满自由不羁精神的 Liquid IV 夏日时光。比如他们回归的粉丝最爱——水合倍增器棉花糖味。对，这就是一种口味。一个充满科技色彩的水合梦境。绝无虚浮，全都是实打实的功能性益处，还带有香甜的香草味。只需一小条 Liquid IV，就能比单喝水更好地为你补水，其电解质含量是顶级运动饮料的三倍，外加八种必需维生素和营养成分。
So the next trip that you go on that you know you're gonna be somewhere that's like hot and humid or wherever which is basically everywhere. Make sure you have a liquid IV on you or in your car or just traveling with you in any way because it really really helps hydrate you and keep you hydrated. Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration with Liquid IV. Get 20% off your first order of Liquid IV when you go to liquidiv.com and use code SMARTLESS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code SMARTLESS at liquidiv.com. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
So the next trip that you go on that you know you're gonna be somewhere that's like hot and humid or wherever which is basically everywhere. Make sure you have a liquid IV on you or in your car or just traveling with you in any way because it really really helps hydrate you and keep you hydrated. Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration with Liquid IV. Get 20% off your first order of Liquid IV when you go to liquidiv.com and use code SMARTLESS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code SMARTLESS at liquidiv.com. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.|||所以，当你下一次去旅行，明知自己会去一个闷热潮湿或者类似地方的时候——基本上到处都是这样——请确保你随身携带 Liquid IV，或者放在车里，或者以任何方式伴你旅行，因为它真的真的能极大地帮助你补水并保持水分充足。使用 Liquid IV，将你的普通饮用水变成超凡的补水神器。访问 liquidiv.com，在结账时使用优惠码 SMARTLESS，即可享受 Liquid IV 首单 8 折优惠。访问 liquidiv.com，使用促销码 SMARTLESS 选购更好的补水产品，首单即可享受 8 折优惠。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。
I talked about this before, but it's very, very dangerous to compare yourself and your life to others. I know it's really easy to do that, especially with social media and looking at people's lives who are like, oh, you know, that person's life seems better than mine or they have more than me or whatever it is, but it's really unhealthy and you really gotta check yourself
I talked about this before, but it's very, very dangerous to compare yourself and your life to others. I know it's really easy to do that, especially with social media and looking at people's lives who are like, oh, you know, that person's life seems better than mine or they have more than me or whatever it is, but it's really unhealthy and you really gotta check yourself|||我以前谈论过这个，但是将自己和自己的生活与他人进行比较，是非常非常危险的。我知道这真的很容做到，尤其是有了社交媒体之后，看着别人的生活，心里会想，哦，你知道的，那个人的人生好像比我好，或者他们拥有的比我多，诸如此类的，但这真的非常不健康，你真的必须审视一下自己，
to get off of social media. And what might help you do that and cope with that is therapy, because comparing yourself to others is a total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media and think they've got it all figured out. But the truth is, everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see.
to get off of social media. And what might help you do that and cope with that is therapy, because comparing yourself to others is a total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media and think they've got it all figured out. But the truth is, everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see.|||远离社交媒体。能帮你做到这一点并应对这种情况的方法可能是心理治疗，因为与他人比较绝对是快乐的终结者。看着别人的社交媒体，很容易让人觉得他们把一切都安排得井井有条。但事实是，每个人都有自己不为人知的幕后烦恼。
Therapy can help you focus on what you want instead of what others have, so you can start living your best life. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Stop comparing and start focusing with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelphelp.com slash smartlis.
Therapy can help you focus on what you want instead of what others have, so you can start living your best life. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Stop comparing and start focusing with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelphelp.com slash smartlis.|||心理治疗可以帮你专注于自己真正想要的东西，而不是别人拥有的东西，这样你才能开始过上最好的生活。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活且适合你日程的服务。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师而无需额外费用。通过 BetterHelp 停止比较，专注于自我。今天就访问 betterhelp.com slash smartlis，即可在第一个月享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelphelp.com slash smartlis。
And now back to the show. I love the station, but I never knew what ESPN stood for and I've figured it out a few times and I've still forgotten it. What does ESPN stand for? It did stand for the Entertainment and Sports Programming Network. Because you know the story at the start, in September of 1979, a little bit before that, they went up on a satellite and had a satellite.
And now back to the show. I love the station, but I never knew what ESPN stood for and I've figured it out a few times and I've still forgotten it. What does ESPN stand for? It did stand for the Entertainment and Sports Programming Network. Because you know the story at the start, in September of 1979, a little bit before that, they went up on a satellite and had a satellite.|||现在回到节目中。我很喜欢这个台，但我从来不知道 ESPN 代表什么意思，虽然我查明过好几次，但还是忘。ESPN 代表什么？它代表的是娱乐与体育节目网（Entertainment and Sports Programming Network）。因为你知道最初的故事，在1979年9月，在那之前不久，他们将信号发射到卫星上，拥有了一颗卫星。
And the original idea was they're gonna broadcast Connecticut sports around the state. And they're like, wait a minute, this can be seen everywhere. So let's expand out the idea. And they're like, wait a minute, this can be seen everywhere. So let's expand out the idea. And when I was mentioning all the names, I didn't mention the godfather of it all. Chris.
And the original idea was they're gonna broadcast Connecticut sports around the state. And they're like, wait a minute, this can be seen everywhere. So let's expand out the idea. And they're like, wait a minute, this can be seen everywhere. So let's expand out the idea. And when I was mentioning all the names, I didn't mention the godfather of it all. Chris.|||最初的想法是他们将在全州范围内转播康涅狄格州的体育赛事。然后他们想，等一下，这个到处都能看到。所以让我们扩大这个想法。然后他们想，等一下，这个到处都能看到。所以让我们扩大这个想法。当我提到所有这些名字时，我漏掉了这一切的教父。克里斯。
Chris Berman, who, you know, Chris, Chris with the nicknames and the shtick and the whole deal, the back, back, back, Chris made it cool. And a lot of people tried to emulate Chris or be like Chris, but I think the ones who succeeded like Rich Eisen, Craig Kilborn, Stuart Scott, guys who came on after the main group I talked about,
Chris Berman, who, you know, Chris, Chris with the nicknames and the shtick and the whole deal, the back, back, back, Chris made it cool. And a lot of people tried to emulate Chris or be like Chris, but I think the ones who succeeded like Rich Eisen, Craig Kilborn, Stuart Scott, guys who came on after the main group I talked about,|||克里斯·伯曼，你知道的，克里斯，那个喜欢起绰号、搞怪招、有一套行话的克里斯，“back, back, back”，克里斯把它变得很酷。很多人试图模仿克里斯或成为克里斯，但我认为那些成功的人，比如里奇·艾森、克雷格·基尔伯恩、斯图尔特·斯科特，这些在我刚才提到的核心团队之后出现的人，
they found their own schtick, right? And there was room for somebody like me who's a serious, call the sports, have a little fun with it, but it's not about me cracking one-liners, all the way to the guys who truly came out of comedy like Rich Eisen and Kilbourne. Rich was a stand-up comedian before he came to sports. Dan Patrick too. Dan Patrick, right? What was your favorite Chris Berman nickname?
they found their own schtick, right? And there was room for somebody like me who's a serious, call the sports, have a little fun with it, but it's not about me cracking one-liners, all the way to the guys who truly came out of comedy like Rich Eisen and Kilbourne. Rich was a stand-up comedian before he came to sports. Dan Patrick too. Dan Patrick, right? What was your favorite Chris Berman nickname?|||他们找到了自己的绝招，对吧？这里有适合我这样的人的空间——一个认认真真解说体育、在其中寻找一点乐趣、但重点不是抖机灵的人，一直到那些真正出身喜剧界的人，比如里奇·艾森和基尔伯恩。里奇在进入体育界之前曾是一名单口喜剧演员。丹·帕特里克也是。丹·帕特里克，对吧？你最喜欢克里斯·伯曼起的哪个绰号？
Because I know mine that I have. Burt B. Home Blylevin. Mine was Eric sleeping with Bayanami. That's exactly. So here's a stupid story. So Syracuse is big for sportscasters and a lot of kids who want to be sportscasters go there and 30 something years later, it's almost 40 years later now. God, it's still the case. So we had just a bunch of nerds and that was our fraternity.
Because I know mine that I have. Burt B. Home Blylevin. Mine was Eric sleeping with Bayanami. That's exactly. So here's a stupid story. So Syracuse is big for sportscasters and a lot of kids who want to be sportscasters go there and 30 something years later, it's almost 40 years later now. God, it's still the case. So we had just a bunch of nerds and that was our fraternity.|||因为我知道我自己的那个。伯特·B·霍姆·布莱莱文。我的是埃里克和巴亚纳米睡觉。完全正确。所以这里有一个蠢故事。锡拉丘兹大学盛产体育播报员，许多想成为体育播报员的孩子都去那里，30多年后，现在快过去40年了。天哪，情况依然如此。所以我们当时只是一群书呆子，那就是我们的兄弟会。
We all want to be sportscasters and a bunch of us turned out to be so we would keep a legal pad by RTV and write down every Chris Berman nickname when it was no way like a community list and we sent it to ESPN We were pissed because ESPN never sent a thank-you note back whatever, you know months later ESPN put out a list of all the Chris Berman nicknames. So we take credit for that, at least in our own hearts. Oh my god, that's good. They're listening right now and they are filled with shame.
We all want to be sportscasters and a bunch of us turned out to be so we would keep a legal pad by RTV and write down every Chris Berman nickname when it was no way like a community list and we sent it to ESPN We were pissed because ESPN never sent a thank-you note back whatever, you know months later ESPN put out a list of all the Chris Berman nicknames. So we take credit for that, at least in our own hearts. Oh my god, that's good. They're listening right now and they are filled with shame.|||我们都想成为体育播报员，我们当中确实有很多后来成了播报员，所以我们会在 RTV 旁边放一本法律记事本，把克里斯·伯曼的每一个绰号都记下来，那感觉就像是一个社区名单，我们把它寄给了 ESPN。我们当时很生气，因为 ESPN 从来没有回寄感谢信什么的，你知道的，几个月后，ESPN 公布了一份克里斯·伯曼所有绰号的清单。所以我们把功劳归于自己，至少在心里是这样的。天哪，太棒了。他们现在正在听节目，心里一定充满羞愧。
They should be. They hired you and they still didn't give you credit. A meeting was just convened in one of the conference rooms, everybody in. Mike, I have a question. Have you ever, when you, when you are calling a game and you do it all the time week after week after week after week What do you do when you're just like really not in the fucking mood to do this?
They should be. They hired you and they still didn't give you credit. A meeting was just convened in one of the conference rooms, everybody in. Mike, I have a question. Have you ever, when you, when you are calling a game and you do it all the time week after week after week after week What do you do when you're just like really not in the fucking mood to do this?|||他们确实应该羞愧。他们雇用了你，却还是不肯给你署名。某间会议室刚刚召开了一个会议，所有人都在内。迈克，我有一个问题。你有没有过这样的时候——当你，当你正在解说一场比赛，而且你每周、每周、每周、每周都在不断重复这项工作——当你真的他妈的一点心情都没有的时候，你会怎么做？
Like how do you you must have like days and you're like how am I gonna get it up for this your pill of choice Mike? Shawn wants you to take this he wants to make some news here. You know what? One, well it's a couple of things. Fortunately you're at games almost all the time. Yeah. And it's 50, 60 thousand people so you guys have performed in front of audiences. There are nights everybody doesn't have it. Something's going on, family, you're sick, you've traveled for 15 weeks, nobody cares, right? You're always trying to make sure that you reach a standard
Like how do you you must have like days and you're like how am I gonna get it up for this your pill of choice Mike? Shawn wants you to take this he wants to make some news here. You know what? One, well it's a couple of things. Fortunately you're at games almost all the time. Yeah. And it's 50, 60 thousand people so you guys have performed in front of audiences. There are nights everybody doesn't have it. Something's going on, family, you're sick, you've traveled for 15 weeks, nobody cares, right? You're always trying to make sure that you reach a standard|||比如你肯定有几天会想“我该怎么打起精神来面对这个”？你选择的药丸是什么，迈克？肖恩想让你吃这个，他想在这里搞点新闻。你知道吗？第一，嗯，有几个原因。幸运的是，你几乎总是置身于比赛现场。是的。现场有五、六万观众，所以你们都曾在观众面前表演过。总会有那么几个夜晚，每个人都不在状态。家里有事、你生病了、你已经连续出差了15周，根本没人管这些，对吧？你总是试图确保自己能达到一个标准，
that you've established over the year. So you just tap into that and like. A little bit of that, but also the crowd. I'm like, look, those people are spending money. And the millions of people watching too, yeah. Exactly, but even like, where do you look for just the raw energy for you if your energy's a little bit low?
that you've established over the year. So you just tap into that and like. A little bit of that, but also the crowd. I'm like, look, those people are spending money. And the millions of people watching too, yeah. Exactly, but even like, where do you look for just the raw energy for you if your energy's a little bit low?|||这个标准是你这一年来建立起来的。所以你只需调动那个状态，然后……有点这方面的原因，但也来源于观众。我心想，看吧，那些人花钱来看比赛了。还有成千上万在屏幕前观看的人，对。没错，但即使如此，当你觉得自己的能量有点低时，你会从哪里寻找那种纯粹的动力？
Look at these people. Jason? Oh. Guys. They tailgated, they parked, they've been there for eight hours and now they're screaming at the top of their lungs, they painted their faces, they're wearing their jersey.
Look at these people. Jason? Oh. Guys. They tailgated, they parked, they've been there for eight hours and now they're screaming at the top of their lungs, they painted their faces, they're wearing their jersey.|||看看这些人。杰森？哦。伙计们。他们聚在一起烤肉尾随派对、停好车，已经在那里待了八个小时了，现在正扯着嗓子大喊大叫，脸上涂着彩绘，身上穿着球衣。
Like, that gets you going, how does it not? So when it's a bad day or it's not the best day, that usually picks me up. You know, Mike, you're saying they painted their faces, it always seemed to me like a really funny tableau would be like one of those guys, one of those like crazy Raiders fans, you know? He's got the silver and he's got the horns
Like, that gets you going, how does it not? So when it's a bad day or it's not the best day, that usually picks me up. You know, Mike, you're saying they painted their faces, it always seemed to me like a really funny tableau would be like one of those guys, one of those like crazy Raiders fans, you know? He's the silver and he's the horns|||这难道不会让你兴奋起来吗？所以当遇到糟糕的一天或者状态不是最好的时候，那通常能让我振作起来。你知道吗，迈克，你刚才说他们画了脸，在我看来，有一个画面总是非常搞笑，那就是那种人，比如那种疯狂的突袭者队球迷，你知道的？他涂着银色，戴着牛角
and he's wearing the shoulder pads with the spikes and stuff and just like half a mile from the stadium exchanging insurance information And with bifocals on bifocals on going honey, it's not the can you pass me the other one? Yeah, it's not the right I mean, you know, I can't read this. I was I was also thinking about Mike You know, like when you were saying that, you know, you we've all performed and stuff I I want I used to watch from my three older brothers. They all played football Everybody I was surrounded by sports, you know growing up and I played sports too. Then I kind of you know my story. So then
and he's wearing the shoulder pads with the spikes and stuff and just like half a mile from the stadium exchanging insurance information And with bifocals on bifocals on going honey, it's not the can you pass me the other one? Yeah, it's not the right I mean, you know, I can't read this. I was I was also thinking about Mike You know, like when you were saying that, you know, you we've all performed and stuff I I want I used to watch from my three older brothers. They all played football Everybody I was surrounded by sports, you know growing up and I played sports too. Then I kind of you know my story. So then|||穿着带有尖刺之类的护肩，就在离体育场半英里远的地方交换保险理赔信息，还戴着双焦眼镜，戴着双焦眼镜说，亲爱的，这不是——能把另一个递给我吗？对，这不是正确的——我是说，你知道的，我看不清这个。我刚才还在想，迈克，你知道的，就像你刚才说的，我们都曾登台表演过之类的事情，我以前经常看着我的三个哥哥。他们都踢橄榄球。我成长过程中周围全是体育，你知道的，我也踢体育。然后我大概——你知道我的故事。所以后来
Then I didn't like sports but But now I'm really into football and these guys know and I do watch it every year and I really, really am into the stories like you guys are talking about and outlining all the people, the players, and then you get to know them and then you get to root for them or whatever your team is, whatever.
Then I didn't like sports but But now I'm really into football and these guys know and I do watch it every year and I really, really am into the stories like you guys are talking about and outlining all the people, the players, and then you get to know them and then you get to root for them or whatever your team is, whatever.|||然后我就不喜欢体育了，但是现在我真的很迷橄榄球，这些家伙都知道，我每年都会看，我真的、真的很喜欢你们刚才谈论的那种故事，了解所有的人和球员，然后你开始认识他们，接着你就会支持他们，无论你支持哪个队都无所谓。
So I get it, but what I really honed in on in the last couple years was the performance of the players and I never really noticed it before. So being an actor, I noticed that like, wait a minute, these guys are really kind of playing it up for the cameras because there's this, like you said, a stadium of tens of thousands of people, there's millions of people watching. If nobody was there and nobody's watching,
所以我懂，但在过去几年里，我真正专注的是球员的表现，我以前从来没有真正注意到这一点。所以作为一个演员，我注意到，等等，这些家伙其实是在对着镜头演戏，因为就像你说的，这里有成千上万人的体育场，有几百万人在观看。如果没有人在场，也没有人在看，
they probably wouldn't get as angry or push as hard or kind of yell back as hard. You know what I mean? They kind of heighten their performance a little bit. Don't you agree? I do, and I'm gonna say that, you know, this Amdur psychological analysis of this, I think it's the generation that's grown up
他们可能就不会那么生气，或者不会那么拼命，或者不会那么大声地回吼。你知道我的意思吗？他们有点在放大自己的表现。你不觉得吗？我确实这么认为，而且我要说的是，你知道，安杜尔对这种现象的心理分析，我认为这是在
in front of cameras. Yeah, I agree. Like they know where the camera is, how to play to it. They know, I score a touchdown, this is my marketing moment. You know, you got guys who have their TD celebrations all rehearsed, they know it's on me right now,
镜头前长大的这一代人。是的，我同意。就像他们知道镜头在哪里，知道怎么对着镜头表现。他们知道，我达阵了，这是我的营销时刻。你知道的，有些家伙的达阵庆祝动作都是排练好的，他们知道现在镜头全在我身上，
and point to the name on the back of their jersey. So they get it. Yeah, Terrell Owens started it with the Sharpie in his shoes. Yes, right. Exactly. But even the broadcasts have specific cameras set up and screens set up in the end zone for them all to gather and do basically their selfie.
然后指着球衣背面的名字。所以他们懂的。没错，特雷尔·欧文开始用鞋里的记号笔庆祝的。对，没错。正是如此。但就连转播也为他们设置了特定的摄像机和在终点区设置了屏幕，让他们所有人聚集在一起，基本上是搞自拍。
Yeah. So that was a COVID thing. It was a COVID thing because there were no fans. So there was like a fan cam so you could watch the game like on a zoom and you sit there and you're watching the game and hey in the third quarter your face will be in the end zone and then they're going yay into their computers. And the guys were seeing them because they were just trying to find a way
对。所以那是新冠时期的产物。那是新冠时期的产物，因为当时没有粉丝。所以当时有个粉丝摄像头，你可以像用Zoom一样看比赛，你坐在那里看着比赛，嘿，第三节的时候你的脸会出现在终点区，然后他们对着电脑喊“耶”。而球员们能看到他们，因为他们只是在想方设法
to create some atmosphere. Right, but the drama seems to always just be a little bit more than you. Well, you talk about performance, you talk about soccer, right? Well, I mean, the flopping is just like, it keeps me away from watching it a lot. No, yeah, but it does, look, it is bad.
营造一些气氛。没错，但这种戏剧性似乎总是比你……好吧，你讲到表现，你讲到足球，对吧？好吧，我的意思是，假摔这种事，真的让我对看比赛提不起兴趣。不，对，但确实如此，你看，这真的很糟。
And certainly, it's worse than others. La Liga is the worst and I would also say League one in France, but La Liga is full of floppers and it's not just the Spanish guys So you guys don't get will start it. No, it's true. Some of these guys I watched I watched that Champions League final. Yeah, you know the other day the barista Dortmund rail and there was there was a Vinny jr Who's a tremendous football player. He didn't even get touched, and he looked like he was shot that a sniper had taken him.
而且当然，有些联赛比别的更严重。西甲是最严重的，我还要加上法甲，但西甲到处都是假摔的人，而且不仅仅是西班牙人，所以你们不会……我们会从那开始。不，这是真的。我看到的其中一些家伙，我看了那场欧冠决赛。是的，你知道，前几天多特蒙德对皇马，当时有维尼修斯·儒尼奥尔，
My two favorites are the triple barrel roll. When the guy goes down, he rolls, and he rolls, and he rolls again. Actually gains speed. Yes, and then when they bring out these million, million pound players in terms of their financial remuneration and they're kind of carrying them on this rickety little thing with two wood sticks and a piece of canvas, they carry them over to the sideline and all of a sudden
他是一个非常棒的足球运动员。他甚至都没被碰到，看起来却像是被狙击手击中了，就像中枪了一样。我最喜欢的两个动作是三连翻。当这家伙倒下时，他翻滚，翻滚，再翻滚。甚至还加速了。是的，然后当他们把这些身价数百万英镑的球员抬下去时——就他们的经济报酬而言——他们用一个带两根木棍和一块帆布的破烂小担架把他们抬到场边，突然之间
they realize their team has the ball, they're right back in the game. Well the other one Mike I like is the guy, he gets sort of tapped in his thigh and he grabs his face. And you're like, wait a second, why are you grabbing your face? But I will say, you know, so thank you for bringing up football, soccer, if you will, because that is one of those sports that for me, I was able to get into it. I'm really a new super fan to it in the last 10 years. But because of the stories, because I was, I watched it with people who knew
他们意识到自己的球队拿到了球，马上又生龙活虎地回到场上了。好吧，另一个我喜欢的招数是迈克，这家伙大腿被轻轻碰了一下，却捂着自己的脸。然后你会想，等一下，你为什么捂着脸？不过我要说的是，谢谢你提起足球，如果你愿意的话也可以叫美式足球，因为那是我能够真正投入进去的运动之一。在过去的10年里，我真的成了它的超级粉丝。但因为这些故事，因为我当时是和懂球的人一起看的，
and they'd film me and they'd say, this guy came from here, this manager came from here, here's what the backstory is. Yeah, I mean, Will always used to say that to me. Like, I was like, how can you watch it? He's like, Sean, watch the story. And that's like the Formula One show on Netflix. That got a bunch of folks into Formula One. So I started watching like Sunderland Till I Die. I was already into that one. Sunderland Till I Die was already in that that point but Sunderland till I die all those It's like reality shows. It's like any time of reality competition show you get to know the people and then you write
他们会向我介绍，这个家伙是从哪来的，这个教练是从哪来的，背景故事是什么。是的，我的意思是，威尔以前总是这么跟我说。比如，我当时问，你怎么能看得下去？他说，肖恩，看故事。就像Netflix上的那部F1赛车纪录片。那让一大批人迷上了F1。所以我开始看像《桑德兰：生命不息》这样的纪录片。我当时已经迷上那个了。《桑德兰：生命不息》那时候已经……但《桑德兰：生命不息》所有这些，就像真人秀。就像任何真人秀竞技节目一样，你开始了解这些人，然后你写——
It's the human story you can relate to it at that point. You can relate to it on a human level So the thing with soccer football soccer whatever sure we're in America soccer The thing with that is it starts. It's rooted in tribalism It's those small towns like a Sunderland, which you mentioned in England, the city, like you end up going to the grounds and a lot of kids walk there and it becomes part of you. Now it's kind of grown from a very tribal and local thing
这就是人性故事，在那一点上你能与之产生共鸣。你能在人性的层面上与它产生共鸣。所以关于足球，美式足球，管它叫什么都行，当然我们在美国叫它足球。它的根源在于部落主义。它源于那些小镇，比如你提到的英格兰的桑德兰，那座城市，你最终会去到球场，许多孩子步行去那里，这成了你的一部分。现在它已经从一种非常部落化和地方化的东西
to regional, national, and global, which has just allowed the expansion of all this to happen. But at its roots, especially if you go over to soccer in England It's it's our neighborhood. It's our team There are guys and we can be mad at them, but you can't yeah love that about this Yeah, Mike, you know so a couple weeks ago I went I went over I went over to go to see your in Klopp's second last home game You're getting trouble and and I'm a huge fan of his. Is that a Chris Berman nickname?
发展成了区域性、全国性乃至全球性的东西，这使得这一切的扩张成为可能。但在它的根基处，特别是如果你去到英格兰看足球，那是我们的社区，那是我们的球队。那里有这样一群人，我们可以对他们生气，但你不能……是的，我太喜欢这个了。是的，迈克，你知道，几周前我去了，我去看克洛普倒数第二场主场比赛了。你惹上麻烦了，而且我是他的超级粉丝。那是克里斯·伯曼式的绰号吗？
Yeah, you're in trouble. Sean just does it on the first name stuff. I had the great fortune of being able to spend a little bit of time with him the past year. Oh, cool. Yeah, yeah. And so I got to go over to Anfield and you walk into that stadium and you listen. First of all, and I went to Chelsea as well. My friend joked that I went to watch Tottenham lose twice in a week. So I went to Stanford Bridge, but I went to Anfield, and I was sitting up there, and I
对，你惹上麻烦了。肖恩总是用名字来开玩笑。我有幸在过去的一年里能花一点时间跟他在一起。哦，太酷了。是的，是的。所以我得以去安菲尔德，你走进那个球场，聆听。首先，我也去了切尔西。我的朋友开玩笑说，我去看热刺在一周内输了两次球。所以我去了斯坦福桥，但我去了安菲尔德，我坐在上面，我
was sitting in front of Sir Kenny Doglish. And the stand opposite us is the Sir Kenneth Doglish stand. And he was a former player, manager, legend, and a Liverpool legend, and a really tremendous guy. He's sitting right behind me with his wife. And they start playing at Anfield, You Never Walk Alone, which is their anthem. And the whole stadium is singing. You know, 60,000 people singing You Never Walk Alone.
坐在肯尼·达格利什爵士的前面。我们正对面的看台就是肯尼斯·达格利什爵士看台。他曾是一名球员、经理、传奇人物，也是利物浦的传奇人物，一个非常了不起的人。他和他的妻子就坐在我身后。安菲尔德开始播放《你永远不会独行》，这是他们的队歌。整个体育场都在歌唱。你知道的，六万人齐声高唱《你永远不会独行》。
And I turn around and his wife, who must have heard it 50,000 times in her life, because her husband was a player manager, and I look back and she's dabbing her eyes. It's so cool. And I thought like, and it was so incredible. It was so moving. So, so moving.
我转过身去，他的妻子——她这辈子一定听过这首歌五万次了，因为她的丈夫曾是球员兼经理——我回头一看，她正在轻轻擦拭眼泪。太酷了。我想，这真是太不可思议了。太感人了，太感人了。
There's something about the way that you're right, that they celebrate that. Well, there's something about sports. Like, most of us never meet the athletes who we wear their jerseys. You know, the old hockey line, you know, you go to a hockey game, especially where I live in Michigan,
你们说得对，他们庆祝的方式确实有些特别。好吧，体育就是这样。比如，我们大多数人从未见过那些我们穿着他们球衣的运动员。你知道，老冰球梗，你知道的，你去观看一场冰球比赛，尤其是像我居住的密歇根州，
and you got a bunch of people walking around with other guys' last names on their back, right? Really, but it's the one place, not only is it acceptable, it's encouraged. And it shows that you're a real fan, right? So- And it brings people together that don't know each other. Well, that's it.
你会看到一群人身上印着其他家伙的姓氏走来走去，对吧？真的，但这是唯一一个不仅被接受，而且受到鼓励的地方。这表明你是一个真正的球迷，对吧？所以——这也把互不相识的人聚集在了一起。好吧，就是这样。
That's the last thing we have, right? I think so too. My stump speech about sports, and the value of sports is, let's go to New Orleans for a Saints game. And let me take one section of the Superdome, and I'm going to get black and white, I'm going to get male and female, I'm going to get straight and gay, I'm going to get different religions,
这是我们最后的阵地了，对吧？我也这么认为。我对体育的宏论，以及体育的价值在于，让我们去新奥尔良看一场圣徒队的比赛。让我占据超级穹顶球场的一个区域，里面会有黑人和白人，会有男性和女性，会有同性恋和异性恋，会有不同的宗教信仰，
I'm going to get everybody in that section. And they're all wearing some black and gold for the Saints. And that doesn't happen at the opera, it doesn't happen at the movies. That's why I still think sports has this place, whereas everything's become so fractured, people still love their sports like nothing else. Mike, has anybody ever said this to you? Because this is my own personal experience,
我会把那个区域里的每个人都涵盖进去。他们都穿着圣徒队的黑金应援服。这种事在歌剧院不会发生，在电影院也不会发生。这就是为什么我仍然认为体育有它独特的地位，当其他一切都变得四分五裂时，人们依然像热爱生命一样热爱他们的体育。迈克，有人跟你说过这话吗？因为这是我个人的亲身体验，
is that no matter what's going on in my life, we all have ups and downs, as you said, we have moments in the family, whatever. And the one thing that I can do to kind we all have ups and downs as you said we have moments and the family whatever and the one thing that I can do to kind of self-regulate is I come home and if I can turn on sports I kind of go everything's okay. Yeah, yeah, right. Do you do that? Oh, it settles me. Yeah, you both both of you check out when sports are on Yeah, and I'd love nothing more than primetime sports when you put on a game that's on at night Yeah, it's like it's like watching this old When you put on a game that's on at night,
那就是无论我的生活发生了什么，我们都会经历起起落落，正如你所说，我们在家庭等方面都会有各种时刻。而我能做的自我调节的一件事就是，我回到家，如果我能打开体育节目，我就会觉得一切都好。是的，是的，对吧？你也会这样吗？噢，这让我平静下来。是的，你们两个，只要有体育节目就会放松。是的，我最喜欢黄金时段的体育节目，当你打开一场晚上进行的比赛，
it's like watching This Old House on PBS on a Sunday afternoon. Oh, Sean. That, but good. We're having a good conversation here. Yeah. I'm an HGTV guy, Sean, if you wanna know the truth. I like it too, I like it too.
这感觉就像……就像在周日下午看公共电视台PBS的《老房子》节目一样。哦，肖恩。那个比喻，不过说得好。我们这聊得很开心呢。是的。肖恩，说实话我是个家居电视网（HGTV）迷。我也喜欢，我也喜欢。
No, Sean, you turn me under the show. I'm not going to. No, I like This Old House, to be honest. Wait, Mike, where are you from? I'm from Queens, from New York. Oh, okay. Grew up as a New Yorker, lived in the Northeast most of my life. Does that make you a Mets fan?
不，肖恩，你把我带进节目里了。我才不呢。不，说实话我挺喜欢《老房子》的。等等，迈克，你是哪里人？我来自纽约皇后区。哦，原来如此。在纽约长大，大半辈子都住在东北部。这说明你是个大都会队的球迷吗？
I wasn't, a Mets and a Jets fan, yeah. Yeah, of course. What did we say was? You had to be agnostic as you went into your profession? Well, the Mets thing was I just wanted to see them win the World Series once in my life, and they did, and I kinda outgrew it. It's like an allergy, you know?
我不是，我是大都会队和喷气式飞机队的球迷，对。是的，当然。我们刚才怎么说的？你进入这个行业时必须保持中立？好吧，关于大都会队，我只是想在我的一生中看他们赢得一次世界大赛冠军，他们做到了，而我也算是对它释怀了。就像对某种东西过敏一样，你知道吗？
They say, hopefully you kinda outgrew it. It's like an allergy, you know? They say, hopefully I outgrew it. So I've saved myself generations of pain after that. And then the rest of it, really, you do become agnostic. People say, well, how can you watch a game and not root? There's one team in sports that I root for, and that's Syracuse, that's my alma mater. Right, gotcha. My God kid goes there.
他们说，希望你最终能对它释怀。就像过敏一样，你知道吗？他们说，希望我能对它释怀。所以在那之后，我为自己省去了好几代人的痛苦。从那以后，真的，你就变得中立了。人们会说，天哪，你怎么能看比赛而不支持任何一方呢？在体育界我只支持一支球队，那就是锡拉丘兹大学，那是我的母校。没错，明白了。我的教子就在那里上学。
Oh, really? No. Yeah, no way. Sammy is dead. The Orange Men, right? Awesome. What? With the Orange, we used to be the Orange Men and Women. That's my alma mater right sure my god kid goes there. Oh really yeah Right what's your orange? We used to be the orange men and women now. We're just the orange now. Just the orange All right, I get it a color a fruit or a spirit you take your pick my godson lives in America You strike me as a fella that would have great chemistry with anyone because you're such a kind guy. But I'll bet Chris Collinsworth doesn't make it difficult. He seems like just about the best guy in the world. I've talked to him a couple of times, but not longer than what I'm talking with you. But still he seems just incredible. Is he as nice a guy as he seems to work with?
哦，真的吗？不是吧。对，没开玩笑。萨米快死了。橙人队，对吧？太棒了。什么？橙人队，我们以前叫橙色男女队。那是我的母校，当然。我的教子就在那里上学。哦，真的吗？对，没错。什么，你们的橙色？我们以前叫橙色男女队，现在我们只叫橙色了。就叫橙色。好吧，我懂了，一种颜色，一种水果还是一种精神，随你挑。我的教子住在美国。你看上去是一个能和任何人都有极好化学反应的家伙，因为你是个如此善良的人。不过我敢打赌克里斯·柯林斯沃思也没给你制造什么困难。他看起来简直是世界上最好的人。我和他聊过几次，但时间没有现在和你聊得这么长。不过他看起来还是那么不可思议。他真像表面上看起来那么好相处吗？
1000%, I'll give you just a quick anecdote. Like, you do this so you kind of know people, but you're not around them. Then I start working at NBC, and I get to be around Chris a little bit more, and I get to know him. And Chris and Al Michaels were a terrific team doing Sunday Night Football for a long time.
1000%是的，我给你讲个小插曲。比如，你做这行所以你多少了解这些人，但你并不常和他们在一起。后来我开始在NBC工作，我能有更多机会和克里斯在一起，我也开始真正了解他。克里斯和阿尔·迈克尔斯长期以来一直是搭档转播《周日橄榄球之夜》的王牌组合。
Al is a buddy of Will and I's. We love Al DeDeath. Yeah, it's great. On the Mount Rushmore. One of the best, if not the best, in every sport to ever do it, right? So I get to start working with Chris, and you know, Chris made it so easy for me. He's like, hey, do the game you do. We can do things a little bit different. It's fine. And he's that way professionally, but he's also that way personally. Chris, his wife Holly, they're kids. They've become friends of me and my wife, our kids.
阿尔是威尔和我共同的好友。我们爱死阿尔了。是的，太棒了。堪称总统山级别。无论在哪个运动项目中，他都是史上最顶尖的解说员之一，甚至可以说是最好的，对吧？所以我开始和克里斯合作，你知道的，克里斯让我感觉非常轻松。他说，嘿，按你习惯的方式解说比赛就行。我们可以把事情做得稍微有点不同。没关系的。他在职业上是这样，在个人生活中也是如此。克里斯，他的妻子霍莉，还有他们的孩子。他们都成了我和我妻子以及我们孩子的朋友。
And that helps, because when you're on the air on Sunday night, you're just sitting with a friend watching a game. And I think that makes it easy on Sunday night at nine o'clock. You're not listening to two people trying to compete. We're trying to be our parts in the symphony. Yeah, no, you guys nailed it.
这很有帮助，因为当你在周日晚上的节目中直播时，你其实只是和朋友坐在一起看比赛。我认为这让周日晚上九点的直播变得轻松惬意。你听到的不是两个人在试图争夺风头。我们只是在努力扮演好交响乐团里的各自角色。是的，没错，你们配合得天衣无缝。
Because that's exactly the feeling that I get when I sit down to watch the game with you guys, is that it just feels like you're right there in the cozy, you know, on the couch right there with us. But you know, the reason it happens like that is... Is because Jason's on a gummy? Yeah. Oh, no sorry. Everything is just part of it. Everything is so smooth. It feels like I'm right there. I can hear you in my head. Wait, Mike, where do you mostly work out? Where do you live now and then where do you work out of? Where does he work out? Come on. Where do you work from mostly? I work most of the week in my house, I live in Michigan,
因为这正是我和你们一起坐下来看比赛时的感受，就觉得你们好像就坐在那儿，在一个舒适的……你知道的，就和我们一起坐在沙发上。但你知道为什么会有这种感觉吗？……是因为杰森嗑了软糖吗？对。哦，不，抱歉。这一切都只是其中的一部分。一切都那么顺畅。感觉就像我就在那里。我能在脑海里听到你们的声音。等等，迈克，你大部分时间都在哪里工作？你现在住在哪里，平时又在哪里办公？他在哪里工作？拜托。你大部分时间都在哪儿工作？我一周大部分时间都在家里工作，我住在密歇根州，
and then we travel to the games, usually for Sunday night football, we travel on Friday. For the Olympics, we'll get there a week before the opening ceremony. And you're not sick of traveling back and forth? Like, you like where you live? It's a lot, it's a lot, but I've come to love America. I love the fact that I can be dropped
然后我们去各地转播比赛，通常为了《周日橄榄球之夜》，我们会在周五出发。如果是奥运会，我们会在开幕式前一周到达那里。你难道不会对这种频繁的来回奔波感到厌倦吗？比如，你喜欢你住的地方吗？这确实挺奔波的，确实挺多的，但我已经开始热爱美国了。我喜欢这种感觉：我可以被空投到
in like 40 cities in America, and I don't need a map. I know where the restaurants are. I know where you can go for a walk. That is cool. That is cool. It is really cool. I really do feel like I've seen and know our country because you spend three days in Minneapolis.
美国的大约40个城市，而我甚至不需要地图。我知道餐馆在哪里。我知道去哪里散步。这真的很酷。这真的很酷。确实真的很酷。我真的觉得自己见识过并了解我们的国家，因为你在明尼阿波利斯待上三天。
You spend three days in Chicago. Three days in New England. That's cool. I love it. I really do. Now, was there an obstacle, everybody's got a nice obstacle at the very start that they kinda decide they're either gonna push through
你在芝加哥待三天。在新英格兰待三天。这太酷了。我爱极了。真的。那么，当时有什么阻碍吗？每个人在刚开始时都会遇到一个很好的障碍，他们必须决定是迎难而上
or they're gonna hit fuck it and try something else. Was there something that almost derailed the great Mike Tirico? I always wanted to call games, what I'm doing now, right? And my bosses told me, no, you're a studio guy, we need you in the studio. So I volunteered to do games on my day off on Saturday, and work a six day during the basketball season to get a chance in 94 to start, start doing games. And
或者他们会彻底放弃，尝试别的。有什么事差点毁了伟大的迈克·蒂里科吗？我一直想转播比赛，就像我现在做的一样，对吧？我的老板告诉我，不，你是个演播室主持人，我们需要你在演播室。所以我自愿在周六的休息日去转播比赛，在篮球赛季期间连轴转工作六天，以此争取在94年获得开始转播比赛的机会，并且
that's what I always wanted to do. And I'm like, I'm going to prove to you guys that I'm good enough. And it took a couple years. And then, in the end of 96, one of our bosses went to ABC and then he said, hey, you told me that you wanted to start doing some other stuff. Would you like to do some golf? Two events in 96. And then in 97, I got to do golf at ABC.
那正是我一直想做的。我想向你们证明我足够优秀。这花了几年时间。然后在96年底，我们的一个老板去了ABC电视台，然后他对我说，嘿，你不是说过你想开始做点别的事情吗？你想做高尔夫吗？96年做了两场比赛。然后在97年，我得以在ABC电视台解说高尔夫。
And the best thing about starting golf in 1997, that was Tiger's first full year of playing golf. So I got right in when the Tiger era started and golf just pre-took off. Oh my God. We'll be right back. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar.
而且在1997年开始打高尔夫最棒的一点是，那是泰格打高尔夫的第一个完整年。所以我正好赶上了泰格时代的开始，高尔夫球事业也随之腾飞。哦天哪。我们马上回来。SmartList 部分由 Audible 赞助播出。在 Audible 上聆听有助于激发你的想象力。
Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, or any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audio books, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want, with more added all the time.
无论您是听故事、励志广播、专家建议还是您喜爱的任何流派，您都可以从中获得灵感，去想象新的世界、新的可能性、新的思维方式。寻找您喜爱的流派，并在过程中发现新的流派。探索畅销书、新发行作品，以及会员可以无限畅听的数千部包含的有声书、播客和原创作品，并且随时会有更多内容加入。
Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time There's more to imagine when you listen right now. I read the book a long time ago, but I wanted to hear it again It's called Sapiens by Yuval Noah Harari. I hope I'm pronouncing you right You've all hopefully heard of him before get it So this is a book about how we started as a human species and it explores everything from then to now and compares and contrasts. All different ages of the human life, really.
Audible 让您无需挤出额外时间，就能在日常生活中轻松获得灵感与娱乐。现在收听，开启更多想象空间。我很久以前读过这本书，但现在还想再听一遍。它叫《人类简史》，作者是尤瓦尔·赫拉利。希望我发音准确。大家应该都听说过他吧。这本书讲述了我们人类物种是如何起源的，探讨了从那时到现在的一切，并对人类生活的各个不同时代进行了对比与对照。
It's really, really cool. Check it out if you can. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days, audible.com slash smartless. Smartless is brought to you in part by Airbnb.
这真的非常非常酷。有空的话去看看吧。作为Audible会员，您每个月都可以从整个目录中选择一本图书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。请访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。即 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500 以免费试用Audible 30天，网址为 audible.com/smartless。Smartless 部分赞助商为 Airbnb。
I've spoken about Airbnb and how great it was before. I just have a friend of mine who has a bunch of family staying in town and she was like, where am I going to put everybody? And I was like, well, I know you used Airbnb before. There's another Airbnb right down the block from her. So she looked it up online. It was a guest favorite,
我以前说过Airbnb有多好。我刚好有个朋友，有一堆家人来城里住，她就在想，我要把大家都安排在哪儿呢？我就说，嗯，我知道你以前用过Airbnb。她街区正下方就有一家Airbnb。于是她在网上查了一下，那是个房客最爱，
which are like the most loved homes on Airbnb. And she put them in there and they had the best time ever. And they said it was clean, it was convenient. And she also said they had a bunch of games like stocked in one of the cabinets and they had like Jenga or whatever and they played Jenga for hours. By the way, I could totally play Jenga for hours, literally.
就像是Airbnb上最受欢迎的房屋一样。她把它们放了进去，他们玩得开心极了。他们说这里很干净，很方便。她还说，其中一个柜子里备了许多游戏，比如叠叠乐什么的，他们玩了几个小时的叠叠乐。顺便说一句，我真的可以玩好几个小时的叠叠乐，千真万确。
Cause like, I've always wanted to be an architect but I don't have the patience to draw. First of all, I can't draw. I can draw stick figures, that's about it. But like all those measurements. Anyway, what am I talking about? Back to Airbnb. It made it a better stay than a hotel, she said.
因为就像，我一直想成为一名建筑师，但我没有耐心去画画。首先，我不会画画。我只会画火柴人，也就仅此而已。但还有那些测量。总之，我在说什么呢？回到爱彼迎。她说，这让住宿体验比酒店更好。
And it really created memories for them for a lifetime. Because you know what? Some trips are better in an Airbnb. SmartList gets support from Vanta. Whether you're starting or scaling your company's security program, demonstrating top-notch security practices and establishing trust is more important than ever. Vanta automates compliance for SOC 2, ISO 27001, HIPAA, and more,
这确实为他们创造了终生难忘的回忆。因为你知道吗？有些旅行选择Airbnb会更好。SmartList得到了Vanta的支持。无论你是刚开始还是在扩展公司的安全项目，展示一流的安全实践并建立信任比以往任何时候都更加重要。Vanta可为SOC 2、ISO 27001、HIPAA等标准实现合规自动化，
saving you time and money while helping you build customer trust. Plus, you can streamline security reviews by automating questionnaires and demonstrating your security posture with a customer-facing trust center all powered by Vanta AI. Over 7,000 global companies like Atlassian, Flow Health, and Quora use Vanta to manage risk and improve security in real time. Get $1,000 off Vanta when you go to vanta.com slash smartlis. That's vanta.com slash smartlis for $1,000 off. at www.hamskey.com. Hello, I'm Elizabeth Day. You might know me as the creator and host of the How to Fail podcast,
为您节省时间和金钱，同时帮助您建立客户信任。此外，您可以通过自动化问卷调查来简化安全审查，并通过面向客户的信任中心展示您的安全态势，所有这些都由 Vanta AI 提供支持。包括 Atlassian、Flow Health 和 Quora 在内的全球 7,000 多家公司使用 Vanta 来实时管理风险和提高安全性。访问 vanta.com 斜杠 smartlis 购买 Vanta 即可立减 1,000 美元。即 vanta.com 斜杠 smartlis 立减 1,000 美元。网址为 www.hamskey.com。您好，我是伊丽莎白·戴。您可能知道我是“如何失败”播客的创始人和主持人，
but I want to tell you about a new podcast I've made. How to Write a Book is for anyone who wants to get their story out there. Fronted by a bestselling author, a super agent, and a powerhouse publisher, this 12-week masterclass will take you right through from developing an idea to nailing the plot. If you want to get all episodes at once and completely ad-free, subscribe now. Listen now wherever you get your podcasts.
但我想要向你介绍我制作的一档新播客。《如何写书》专为任何想要把自己的故事讲给世界听的人而设。由一位畅销书作家、一位超级经纪人和一位实力雄厚的出版商共同主持，这个为期12周的大师班将带你从构思一个点子一直走到精确定型情节。如果你想一次性收听所有单集且完全无广告，请立即订阅。现在就在你获取播客的任何地方收听吧。
All right, back to the show. Can I just say something about the Tiger Eric so that we can, because there's been, you know, there's a lot of stuff. That time, we had the privilege, and people say, oh, you like Tiger Eric, and I'm like, we had the privilege of watching one of the all-time great athletic careers
好了，回到节目中。我能关于老虎埃里克说点什么吗？这样我们就可以……因为你知道的，有很多事情。那次，我们有幸——人们会说，哦，你喜欢老虎埃里克，而我觉得——我们有幸见证了史上最伟大的运动员生涯之一
that's ever graced this planet. And we got to watch it in, as you say, JB, in prime time, it was all recorded, we got to see every in, as you say, JB, in prime time. It was all recorded. We got to see every shot. And I thought, what a privilege we had to watch this guy play at the top of his game. It was incredible. And Mike calling the British Open?
曾降临过这个星球。正如你所说，JB，我们在黄金时段观看了它，这一切都被记录了下来，我们看到了每一个——正如你所说，JB，在黄金时段。这一切都被记录了下来。我们看到了每一个击球。我想，我们能看到这家伙在巅峰时期打球是何等的荣幸。这太不可思议了。还有迈克解说英国公开赛？
And Mike, you called it. Yeah. I had a bunch of them. I think I've done like 65 or 66 majors and Tigers played in most of them. Wow. And it's just so, it cover to call, I should say. And like the energy around Tiger is different
麦克，你预测对了。是的。我参加过很多次，我想我已经打过大约65或66场大满贯赛事，而泰格参加了其中大部分。哇。这简直……我该怎么说呢，泰格身边那种能量是完全不同的。
from any other athlete, even Jordan. Now Jordan was, Michael was in a team sport, right? Yeah. And there was still this incredible energy and juice around Michael when he was there. Sure. But when Tiger was 100 yards away, you could just feel it,
来自任何其他运动员，甚至是乔丹。乔丹是，迈克尔参加的是团队运动，对吧？是的。迈克尔在场时，周围仍然有一种令人难以置信的能量和活力。当然。但当泰格在100码外时，你就能真切地感受到它，
you could just see the pack of people following him. Watching people try to go hole by hole, shot by shot, to see Tiger was hysterical. People tripping over each other and trying to run ahead. It was a phenomenon that lasted for a full couple of decades. It was one of the most fascinating things we've ever seen. Sean, it's hard to appreciate it
你可以看到一大群人跟着他。看着大家试图一洞接一洞、一杆接一杆地去看泰勒，真是太滑稽了。人们互相绊倒，拼命往前跑。这种现象持续了足足几十年。这是我们见过最迷人的事情之一。肖恩，这很难让人真正体会到
if you're not a fan of, like, you don't follow golf or whatever, but to understand, to appreciate his winning percentage on that sport compared to other people when he was at his prime, it was like nothing anybody had ever seen. It blew everything else right. I don't understand the eye, brain, body coordination to get it right so many times.
如果你不喜欢，或者不怎么关注高尔夫之类的，但要理解并欣赏他在巅峰时期在该运动中的胜率与其他人相比，那是前所未闻的。它颠覆了一切。我不明白那种眼、脑、身体的协调性怎么能做到那么多次都完美无缺。
Yeah, I mean, you're just incredibly gifted. But what has been almost totally forgotten is how rare it was for a black athlete to be doing this in what was traditionally a white world. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was just, it was, I mean, there was Calvin Pete, for sure, there was- Charlie Sifford, Lee Elder.
是的，我的意思是，你真的极具天赋。但几乎完全被遗忘的是，在传统上属于白人的世界里，一个黑人运动员能做到这一点是多么罕见。是的，是的，是的。当时，就是，我的意思是，当然有卡尔文·皮特，还有——查理·西福德，李·埃尔德。
Yeah, exactly. Those are the couple of black golfers that were on the stage. In hundreds of years, like one of the oldest sports ever, games ever, there were just a handful that you could look to. But then to come and dominate the way he did. And just dominate.
是的，完全正确。那是舞台上仅有的几位黑人高尔夫球手。在几百年的历史中，作为最古老的体育运动和游戏之一，你只能找到区区几位。但随后他的到来，并以那种方式统治了比赛。简直是统治全场。
Exactly, it was like, he was like Michael Jordan. And the thing about his dominance that was so cool to me was when he got the lead, he always closed. He always, all but twice, he always closed the deal going into the final round. And guys spit up the lead every other week, usually, on tour. If not more than that, every week. So he had the impact that Jack Nicklaus had, because if his name was on the leaderboard,
没错，他就好像是迈克尔·乔丹。关于他的统治力，最酷的一点是，当他取得领先时，他总是能锁定胜局。除了区区两次之外，他总是能在进入最后一轮时稳操胜券。而在巡回赛上，选手们通常每隔一周就会把领先优势弄丢，甚至比那更频繁，几乎每周都有。因此，他具有杰克·尼克劳斯那样的影响力，因为只要他的名字出现在记分榜上，
people would watch. I was just at an event with Tom Watson a couple of weeks ago and he said, you know, when you saw Nicklaus's name on the board, you're like, oh, uh-uh. And when you're thinking about somebody else, you're defeated. You're half defeated. And the ratings too.
人们会观看。我几周前刚和汤姆·沃森一起参加了一个活动，他说，你知道的，当你看到尼克劳斯的出现在记分牌上时，你会想，哦，不，不。而当你想到另一个人时，你已经被击败了。你已经输了一半。收视率也是如此。
If those guys make the cut, I'm sure your weekend ratings, it's a huge difference. So a lot of people talk about Caitlin Clark and what she's done with women's basketball, and the ratings are the likes of which we've never seen before, right? She's had an impact on that sport, like Michael did in the NBA and Tiger did,
如果那些家伙入选了，我敢说你们周末的收视率会有巨大的差异。所以很多人都在谈论凯特琳·克拉克以及她对女子篮球运动的贡献，其收视率是我们从未见过的，对吧？她对这项运动产生的影响，就像迈克尔在NBA和泰格在...
just in terms of this. They blew the roof and the ceiling off of where the ratings were. And that'll be the mark that's going to be so hard to get for years to come. Because it was just the first time people have seen it. They wanted to be there and watch it and there was something captivating about them. And they took it to a height that I don't think you'll see in those sports again.
就这一点而言，他们的收视率直接冲破了天花板。这将成为未来几年极难打破的纪录，因为这是人们第一次看到这种景象。人人都想去现场观看，他们身上有一种迷人的特质。他们把这项运动推向了一个我认为很难再复制的高度。
Yeah, but meanwhile, which I'm sure that they'd all be very proud of, they have exposed a ton of people that wouldn't otherwise have been exposed to The game and once they're gone those people are now already into the game and they're gonna watch the next athletes that come through So they're broadening the appeal of the of the of the sport I mean what Jordan did for basketball globally, right him and David Stern working hand-in-hand You know is just is astounding legacy doesn't happen when you try to make it happen. Legacy happens when what you do naturally
是的，但与此同时，我相信他们都会为此感到非常自豪，他们让大量原本不会接触到这款游戏的人接触到了它，而一旦他们离开了，这些人现在就已经迷上了这款游戏，他们会观看接下来出现的运动员，所以他们正在扩大这项运动的吸引力，我的意思是乔丹对全球篮球运动所做的一切，对吧，他和大卫·斯特恩携手合作，你知道，这简直是惊人的传奇，当你试图去实现它时，传奇并不会发生。传奇发生在你自然而然做的事情中
just brings people from all corners because there's something unique and captivating about you. And that's what happened with Jordan, and that's what happened with Tiger. You mentioned just Tiger being black and in a sport that had been so dominated by white players and country clubs and membership and all that stuff, which I think Tiger's presence helped change over time.
吸引着来自各个角落的人们，因为你身上有一种独特而迷人的特质。乔丹是这样，泰格也是这样。你刚才提到泰格身为黑人，却身处一个长期被白人球员、乡村俱乐部和会员制等因素主导的运动中，我认为泰格的出现随着时间的推移有助于改变这种状况。
Sure, to the point where we don't even think about that anymore. It's like a forgotten fact. Well, I don't think it still exists. No, but I mean, it's become, I don't know how to put this, but it was such an anomaly back then. And now there are so many incredible, it's such an expansion to the sport now. Yeah, I thought Tiger was going to change the sport that way, and you'd see a lot more minorities playing
当然，甚至到了我们不再去想它的地步。这就像是一个被遗忘的事实。嗯，我不认为它现在还存在。不，我的意思是，它已经变成了——我不知道该怎么表达，但在当时这是一个多么大的反常现象啊。而现在有了那么多不可思议的——现在这项运动的发展太广阔了。是的，我本以为泰格会以这种方式改变这项运动，你会看到更多的少数族裔参与进来
and becoming the best players. What he did instead, his athletic legacy in the sport beyond his records, he made golf cool and now guys who were 6'1", 6'2", 6'3", started playing golf. And you look at the major change, guys like Brooks Koepka, Tony Finau, etc. You get like some big guys who are now playing golf who would not have played the sport back before Tiger. It wasn't cool to be one of these big athletes who could be a tight end or a shooting forward in basketball.
奶成为最佳球员。他所做的事情——他在这项运动中除了砄分纪录之外的体育传奇——是他让高尔夫球变得酷了，现在身高 6 苻 1 寸、6 苻 2 寸、6 苻 3 寸的小伙子们开始打高尔夫了。而你看看重大变化，像布鲁克·布科普卡、托尼·菲诺等人。你会发现一些大个子现在在打高尔夫，而如果没有泰格，他们原本是不会运动这项运动的。在恪格之前，做一个能够在篮球场上打单捥或在申请引用中捥的大体格迕动员并不酷。
And that I think is Tiger's long-term impact on the sport itself. Yeah, yeah, that's a great point. That's a great point. Well, it definitely attracted a big guy like me, you know? Yeah, look at you, otherwise Will would have never have gone there. Wait, well, my nickname is Big Boy.
而我认为这正是泰格对这项运动本身的长期影响。对，对，说得太好了。说得太好了。嗯，它确实吸引了像我这样的大块头，你知道吗？对，看看你，否则威尔永远不会去那儿。等等，好吧，我的外号叫大块头。
Yeah, go ahead, Sean. This is a standard Sean question from Mike Trico. What's like the worst or most memorable or most embarrassing moment happened to you live that you called or you said something that you regret, not regret, but like that, or that just cracked everybody up and you were like, why did I just say that?
好的，肖恩，请说。这是迈克·特里科提出的一个标准的肖恩式问题：在你进行直播时，发生过什么最糟糕、最难忘或最尴尬的事情吗？比如你说了什么让你后悔的话——倒也不是后悔，就是那种让所有人都捧腹大笑，然后你心里想‘我刚才干嘛要说那句话’的事？
Sean, you got some wood there? I'm gonna knock on it, man. I have gotten through 36 years of doing this without really having a major all-time YouTube screw-up. I'll find one. I'll find one. Here come the Olympics. I'm gonna Google it.
肖恩，你那儿有木头吗？我要敲敲木头，兄弟。我做这行36年了，一直都没出现过那种史诗级的重大YouTube失误。总会被我找到的。总会被我找到的。奥运会要来了。我去谷歌一下。
There you go, thanks so much. You've got yourself all teed up. And I'm gonna blame Sean. It's all on Sean. There was one time I was doing a TV show, a sportscast in Syracuse. I have a nut allergy and I was about to get sick and I got away from the camera before that happened. So nothing's happened in front of a camera. You just blew it out? You blew it out?
就这样，非常感谢。你已经准备妥当了。我要怪肖恩。全怪肖恩。有一次我在做电视节目，雪城的一个体育节目。我对坚果过敏，当时快要吐了，在事情发生前我及时离开镜头。所以镜头前什么都没发生。你刚才直接吐出来了？你吐出来了？
If you want the details, Sean, thank you. Now, are you as excited for the Olympics as I am? I'll bet you are much more, because you know much more about it than I do. But just the little that I've read about it, it sounds like Paris is going to do something with this that we've never seen before, like I think the whole, what, the opening ceremony takes place on the Seine, right, on the river.
肖恩，如果你想要细节的话，谢谢你。那么，你对奥运会的期待和我一样吗？我敢说你比我期待得多得多，因为你对它的了解比我多得多。但就我所读到的那一点点内容来看，听起来巴黎这次要搞一些我们从未见过的大动作，比如我认为整个，什么来着，开幕式将在塞纳河上举行，对吧，就在河上。
The events are taking place at all of the incredible monuments there. I think the whole, what, the opening ceremony takes place on the Seine, right, on the river. The events are taking place at all of the incredible monuments there, like volleyballs underneath the Eiffel Tower and like, and surfing is in Tahiti, you know, because it's a French, you know. On the French Polynesia, man. Yeah, so how? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
这些赛事将在那里的所有不可思议的纪念碑举行。我想整个，什么，开幕式在塞纳河上举行，对吧，在河上。这些赛事将在那里的所有不可思议的纪念碑举行，比如埃菲尔铁塔下的排球，冲浪在塔希提岛，你知道的，因为那是法属的，你知道的。在法属波利尼西亚，老兄。是的，那么怎么？等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
They're gonna do the surfing in Tahiti. In Tahiti? Yes, sir. Because it's a French. I get that, but I understand that I have a full, but I'm surprised, why wouldn't they just do it like down in Bearetts? Well, because it's not as sexy, man.
他们要在大溪地进行冲浪比赛。在大溪地？是的，长官。因为那是一个法国领地。我明白，但我知道我有一个完整的，不过我很惊讶，为什么他们不就在像比雷茨那样的地方办呢？嗯，因为那样不够吸引人，老兄。
That's right, that's exactly right. This is why you're not running things, Will. Well, no, but I might go to Paris. We begged, oh man but we begged our bosses Can we just host the whole Olympics from Tahiti? Something going on there, right? Who cares what the background is right? I mean, it's gotta be you guys are just probably trying to figure out what? How do we cover all the things we want to cover? Yeah, it's gonna be look
没错，完全没错。这就是为什么你当不了家，威尔。好吧，不，但我可能会去大溪地。我们求过，哦天哪，但我们求过我们的老板，我们能不能直接在大溪地转播整届奥运会？那边一定发生了什么事，对吧？谁在乎背景是什么呢？我的意思是，你们可能只是在想怎么做？我们怎么才能报道所有我们想报道的事情？是的，这将会是——瞧
Paris is one of two things either you've been there and you can't wait to go back Well, you've never been there and you want to go. Right? Yeah. And the Olympics needs this in the biggest way. If you think back, the last three Olympics have been in Asia. We had the 2018 Winter Games in Pyeongchang, South Korea.
巴黎有两种情况：要么你去过那里，迫不及待想再去；要么你从未去过，但非常想去。对吧？是的。奥运会极其需要这种魅力。回想一下，最近三届奥运会都在亚洲举行。我们有2018年韩国平昌冬奥会。
Then COVID denied Tokyo 2020. So that was held in 2021, COVID, no fans. And then Beijing held the winter games in the winter of 2022, February. Again, no fans. So we've had two Olympic games with no fans. What do you mean, what do you mean no fans? COVID.
接着新冠疫情让2020年东京奥运会延期了。所以那届奥运会在2021年举行，因为疫情，没有观众。然后北京在2022年冬天的2月举办了冬奥会。同样，没有观众。所以我们已经举办了两届没有观众的奥运会。你是什么意思，你是说没有观众是什么意思？新冠疫情。
Oh, cause people didn't, I see, got it, got it. Because of COVID, there were no fans. And like you guys were mentioning this, somebody mentioned it before. Like you work your whole life to make the Olympics It's four years of training for a minute two minutes, you know, whatever it ends up being for some of the athletes You want your family there and none of the families could go right to Tokyo or to Beijing last summer winter games So that is one of the things that I am more excited about. So is this yeah
噢，因为人们没有，我明白了，懂了，懂了。因为疫情，没有粉丝。就像你们提到的那样，之前也有人提过。你为了参加奥运会努力了一辈子，那是四年的训练，换来了一分钟两分钟，对某些运动员来说可能就是那样。你希望家人能在现场，但去年夏天和冬天的奥运会，没有任何家属能去东京或北京。所以，这也是我最期待的事情之一。所以是这样，对吧
Is this the first time it's gonna be back in full force with just everything and to tell, you know, the way it's televised and the fans and everything? Correct. This will be the first time that fans are in the stands at the Olympics since February of 2018. So six years and about five months or six months. Wow, that's pretty cool. I like the way you put that, Mike.
这是自2018年2月以来，奥运会第一次全面恢复并允许粉丝入场观看，无论是电视转播还是现场观众等各方面都是如此吗？没错。这将是自2018年2月以来奥运看台上首次迎来观众，时隔约五年半到六年。哇，这真酷。迈克，我喜欢你的这种表达方式。
I think you're right. The Olympics need this. Yes. They need Paris to work. They need it to be good. I think you're right the Olympics need this. Yeah, they need Paris to work They need it to be good. They need to be successful. It will be I think it will be I probably will Where are the next Winter Olympics? Well, the next Winter Olympics are Milan and Cortina Italy, right? It's 2026 and then LA is then summer and that's why To what will was just saying that's why I think this is a big games for the Olympic movement and it's in a great place in Paris because as you mentioned the backgrounds That's why, to what Will was just saying, that's why I think this is a big games for
我想你是对的。奥运会需要这个。是的。他们需要巴黎成功。他们需要它办得好。我想你是对的，奥运会需要这个。是的，他们需要巴黎成功，他们需要它办得好。他们需要取得成功。会的，我想会的，我可能会的。下一届冬奥会是在哪里？嗯，下一届冬奥会是意大利的米兰和科尔蒂纳，对吧？那是2026年，然后是洛杉矶夏季奥运会，这就是为什么，正如威刚刚所说的那样，这就是为什么我认为这对奥林匹克运动来说是一届重大的运动会，而且它在巴黎这个绝佳的地方举办，正如你所提到的背景。这就是为什么，正如威刚才所说，这就是为什么我认为这是一届重大的...
the Olympic movement and it's in a great place in Paris because as you mentioned, the backgrounds, Paris is just such an aspirational city. But LA 2028, we haven't had a summer Olympics here since Atlanta back in the late 90s. And we haven't had the Olympics in the US since Salt Lake in 2002. So if you're 30, right? So 26 years between Olympics in the US. If you're 30, you don't ever remember the Olympics being contested in America.
奥运运动在巴黎处于一个极佳的状态，正如你所提到的，那些背景，巴黎真是一座令人向往的城市。但对于2028年洛杉矶奥运会，自90年代末的亚特兰大以来，我们这里就再也没有举办过夏季奥运会了。而且自2002年盐湖城奥运会以来，美国就再也没有举办过奥运会。所以，如果你现在30岁，对吧？也就是美国举办奥运会之间隔了26年。如果你30岁，你根本不记得奥运会在美国举行过。
Right. So now you're 30-year-under-alpha. Well, you're speaking my language. Yeah, I don't remember that. You look terrible, though, Sean, for 25. Sean told me once he went to Paris, he went to L'Homme-y-Louis for dinner, and he had an Olympic movement after that he said.
对。所以你现在是个30岁减去阿尔法的人。好吧，你说的我能听懂。对，我不记得那个了。不过肖恩，25岁的你看上去真糟糕。肖恩曾经告诉我，他去巴黎时，去L'Homme-y-Louis吃晚餐，他说他之后有了一次奥运级别的排便。
Because he had the steak and the chicken. It was the duck. It was the fries they do they cook in goose fat which by the way Lummy Louis nobody does it better it's a very American but it's still great it's so great well all right you convinced me Mike I'm gonna come to Paris this summer. Don't give me your number, Mike. Don't give me your number. Let's read tickets. No, I'm gonna come. Let's go.
因为他吃了牛排和鸡肉。是鸭肉。那是他们用鹅油烹制的薯条，顺便说一句，Lummy Louis，没有人能做得更好了，它非常美国化，但依然很棒，真的太棒了。好吧，迈克，你说的对，我今年夏天要去巴黎。别把你的号码给我，迈克。别把你的号码给我。我们来看机票。不，我要去。走吧。
And I'll share duties with you at the desk. Here we go. You can? You want to host? Go ahead. Do you? You know who's with me? Who's that?
我会在主播台和你分担工作。我们开始吧。你可以吗？你想当主持？去吧。你想吗？你知道谁跟我一起吗？那是谁？
Snoop. No way. No way, really? Really? Oh, no, no. Snoop is, it's not just like Snoop's gonna show up for once. Snoop is part of our
史努比（Snoop）。开什么玩笑。真的假的？真的吗？哦，不，不。史努比，这不仅仅是史努比偶尔露面那么简单。史努比是我们
coverage and he is, he is all in on this man. I love Snoop. He is such a great dude. Where did that come from? He just performed at Jimmy Buffett's memorial, you know that concert we did. He was unbelievable, he's such an unbelievably great guy. But where did that come from Mike? Was that your idea?
报道团队的一员，而且他，他全身心地投入其中，伙计。我太喜欢史努比了。他真是个极品好人。这从何说起呢？他刚刚在吉米·巴菲特的追悼会上表演过，你知道我们办的那场音乐会吗。他简直不可思议，他真的是个好得难以置信的家伙。但这从何说起呢，迈克？那是你的主意吗？
No, no, I wish it was. So we'll go back a few years ago to the last Summer Games. And we're trying to, you know, we have Peacock as part of the NBC family. It's our streaming service. So we're trying to figure out what shows can we do Olympic related on Peacock. So Kevin Hart and Snoop did Olympic highlights, their version of Olympic highlights. They did like a couple of nights during the games. And Snoop, it's a great YouTube clip of Snoop and the Equestrian as like,
不，不，我希望是。让我们回到几年前的上一届夏季奥运会。我们当时正试图，你知道的，我们有作为NBC家族一部分的Peacock。那是我们的流媒体服务。所以我们在想，我们能在Peacock上做哪些与奥运相关的节目。于是凯文·哈特和史努比制作了奥运精彩集锦，他们版本的奥运精彩集锦。他们在比赛期间做了几个晚上的节目。关于史努比和马术，网上有一个很棒的剪辑，
it's like a Crip Walk, right? So, you know, that's where the relationship started, then the conversations continued, and he's going to be a part of it. So here's the deal, like, the Olympics are going to happen live. We used to hold events and just say, hey, we'll show T at night, right? That doesn't happen anymore. Everybody's got a phone. They can find out what happens.
就像是Crip Walk舞步，对吧？所以，你知道的，这就是关系的开始，然后对话一直在继续，他将成为其中的一部分。所以情况是这样的，奥运会将进行现场直播。我们过去常常举办赛事，然后说，嘿，我们会在晚上播放，对吧？那种事不复存在了。每个人都有手机。他们可以查到发生了什么。
So everything's going to be live during the day. It's a six hour time difference. Yes, thank God. It's going to be great. So at night, you're going to be showing everything that happened. So we're going to try to do a little bit of the storytelling, a little bit of the behind the scenes,
所以白天的一切都将是现场直播。有六个小时的时差。是的，谢天谢地。这太棒了。所以在晚上，你们将展示发生过的一切。所以我们要尝试做一点故事叙述，一点幕后花絮，
give you a little bit of flavor of Paris. And who better to snoop around Paris than Snoop. So we're in, let's go. Very, very good. That's really cool. Is the family gonna go with you? My family's gonna come. They've been denied the last two Olympics,
给你一点巴黎的风情。还有谁比史努比更适合在巴黎四处闲逛呢。所以我们加入，走吧。非常好，非常棒。太酷了。你家人要跟你一起去吗？我的家人会去。他们被剥夺了参加前两届奥运会的权利，
which is kind of a bummer. It's the fourth time that I'm the prime time host, and they haven't been able to come to any of them, so they're gonna come over for a week or so and get to it. I won't see them, but they'll have a great time. And they'll have a great time because they won't see me, actually.
这挺让人遗憾的。这是我第四次担任黄金时段主持，而他们都没能去过现场，所以他们打算过来待一周左右，好好体验一下。我不会见到他们，但他们会玩得很开心。而且他们会玩得很开心，因为实际上他们见不到我。
Are your kids loving what you do? Like, are they interested? Or what's your favorite thing to do as a family? It's a great question. Be together at our lake house in Michigan now, because we're away so much with my travel. We have kids who've graduated college, just finished wrapping up their college careers.
你的孩子们喜欢你的工作吗？比如说，他们感兴趣吗？或者你们作为一家人最喜欢做的事情是什么？这是一个好问题。现在是在我们位于密歇根州的湖畔小屋聚在一起，因为我的旅行让我经常不在家。我们有已经大学毕业的孩子，刚刚结束了他们的大学生涯。
That's nice. You're not old enough for college grads. Yeah, we're old people now. So just to know when, and a lot of people who are listening who have older kids, like when your kids become your friends too, it's so cool. So that is like, I can't wait to do that
那挺好的。你还没老到有大学毕业的孩子吧。对，我们现在是老一辈人了。所以要知道什么时候，许多有大孩子的听众都知道，当你的孩子也成为你的朋友时，那种感觉太酷了。所以这就好像，我等不及要那样做了。
I'm excited they're gonna get a chance to do some of this they come to some of the football games from time to time and You know you get a chance to be around it and they they love sports They both played sports in in high school and we're big sports fans that we're in a sports house It's always the topic of conversation a games on, so they're all in on it and they love it. How did you get to Michigan? It's where my wife is from. Okay, gotcha.
我很高兴他们有机会参与其中，他们时不时会去看一些橄榄球比赛，你知道的，你有机会身处其中，他们他们热爱体育，他们俩在高中时都参加过体育运动，我们是超级体育迷，我们生活在一个体育世家里。总是以比赛为话题，所以他们全身心投入并且非常热爱。你怎么会去密歇根的？那是讯我妻子长大的地方。好的，明白了。
Yeah, she was an all-state softball and basketball player in Michigan, and we moved back near her family back in the late 90s, and been here for a long time. It's funny, because she asked me a few years ago, do you consider yourself a Northeasterner, being born in the Northeastern school? I'm like, nah, I'm a long time. It's funny, because she asked me a few years ago, do you consider yourself a Northeasterner, being born in the Northeastern school? I'm like, nah, I'm a Midwest guy.
对，她在密歇根曾是一名全州级别的垒球和篮球运动员，我们在90年代末搬回了她家人附近，并在那里住了很长时间。说来有趣，因为几年前她问我，作为一个在东北部长大的人，你认为自己是东北人吗？我说，不，我是个中西部人。
I love living, especially doing what I do. I love not living on either coast. It's good to be part of the flyover world and just represent us every once in a while. Yeah, I get that. I get that, that makes sense. I bet it's a nice way of living. It is.
我喜欢生活，特别是做我现在做的工作。我喜欢不住在任何一个海岸边。偶尔成为飞越地带（flyover world）的一部分并代表我们发声，感觉挺好的。对，我懂。我懂，这说得通。我敢说这是一种美好的生活方式。确实如此。
Now, when you do the Olympics, you end up doing a lot of interviews too, as well as calling events. Do you have a preference or do you like them both equally? So in the Olympics, I don't call events, I'm hosting, so I just do the daytime and then the prime time hosting. And I love when athletes win medals and they come to sit on the couch with their medals on.
现在，当你报道奥运会时，除了赛事解说，你最终还要做很多采访。你是有偏好，还是两者一样喜欢？所以在奥运会上，我不做赛事解说，我是主持人，所以我只负责白天以及黄金时段的主持。我喜欢运动员赢得奖牌后，带着奖牌来沙发上坐着的时候。
Right, yeah. Because you just get, like that's the moment they dream of, right? And not necessarily sitting with me, I love when athletes win medals and they come to sit on the couch with their medals on. That's the moment they dream of, right? Not necessarily sitting with me, but just being there and being interviewed. You've got the little fireplace going. Yeah, the winter fireplace. The summer this year would be the Eiffel Tower in the background. They just got this heavy medal around their neck and they're just sitting there. I've loved that.
对，没错。因为你会得到，那就是他们梦寐以求的时刻，对吧？倒不一定是跟我坐在一起，我喜欢运动员赢得奖牌后，带着奖牌来沙发上坐着。那是他们梦寐以求的时刻，对吧？倒不一定是非要跟我坐在一起，只是坐在那里接受采访。你旁边有个小壁炉。对，冬奥会的壁炉。今年夏天的背景会是埃菲尔铁塔。他们脖子上挂着沉甸甸的奖牌，就坐在那里。我太喜欢了。
Every time I see an Olympic athlete and get a chance to talk to them or interview them, I always end it with like, hey, I hope I get to interview you with a medal around your neck, right? No matter what color medal it is. And it's just so, that's like one of the terms that translates everywhere.
每次我看到奥运会运动员并有机会和他们交谈或采访他们时，我总是以这样的话结束，嘿，我希望我能有机会采访脖子上挂着奖牌的你，对吧？不管那是什么颜色的奖牌。这简直太，那是那种放之四海皆准的用语之一。
You can be in a village in Africa, you can be in Australia, you can be anywhere Olympian Translates yeah, and the other coolest part of that opening ceremony Which you mentioned before is gonna go down the river send with boat parade of the athletes can be very different Hopefully it'll be so cool spectacular like for most gonna be in Sen No, we'll come on. We got this isn't Sen. It's gonna be a little teaser bite For most of the athletes, that's their Olympic moment, right?
你可以身处非洲的一个村庄，你可以身处澳大利亚，你可以在任何地方，奥运选手这个词是相通的。是的，开幕式的另一个最酷的部分，你之前也提到过，将沿着塞纳河举行运动员船队游行，这将会非常与众不同。希望它会非常酷、壮观。对大多数人来说，要在塞纳河上……不，等等，我们会的，这不是塞纳河。这只是一个简短的预告。对大多数运动员来说，那就是他们的奥运时刻，对吧？
Because they don't get on the podium and sing their anthem. They're only about 350 or a little bit less than that, win gold medals. So their moment is being in the opening ceremony with all the best athletes in the world who made it there. I just, I get a little melancholy and a little sappy about it, but it's so dang cool If you if you could if you could have anybody on that couch, it doesn't need to be an Olympic couch But but talking to any athlete Alive or dead that you haven't interviewed Do you ever think about one that you'd love to sit across from and ask some questions to that? I haven't interviewed. Yeah
因为他们不会登上领奖台高唱国歌。只有大约350人或略少一点的人能赢得金牌。所以他们的时刻就是和全世界所有到达那里的最优秀的运动员一起参加开幕式。我只是，我对此感到有点多愁善感和多情，但它实在是太酷了。如果你能，如果你能让任何人坐在那个沙发上，不一定非得是奥运沙发，但是跟任何在世或已故、你还没采访过的运动员交谈，你会不会想过某个你想坐在他对面并问他一些问题的人，是你还没采访过的？对
That's maybe or maybe one you'd like to interview again that you forgot to ask certain questions to know that that's a really good question I I'd like to talk to Babe Ruth yeah yeah I'd like to talk to babe because like you know here a hundred years ago you had no idea people still be talking about you be a candy bar name that man yeah that no one else would be a pitcher and a hitter until Shohei Otani. Otani, right?
也许或者是你想再次采访的人，你忘了问某些问题。知道吗，这是一个非常好的问题。我想跟贝比·鲁斯（Babe Ruth）谈谈。对，对。我想和贝比聊聊，因为你知道的，一百年前你根本不知道人们还会谈论你，甚至还有一个以你名字命名的糖果棒，伙计。对，除了大谷翔平之外，没有人能既是投手又是打者。大谷，对吧？
Exactly, right? What do you think of Otani, babe? And with AI, we could probably do that. I think he's a hell of a kid. Hey Mike, I'm here for you. Ask me another one. I've had 12 bottles of beer and I'm ready to play. Put me in.
完全正确，对吧？贝比，你觉得大谷怎么样？借助人工智能，我们或许能做到这一点。我觉得他是个了不起的小伙子。嘿，迈克，我为你在这儿呢。再问我一个。我喝了12瓶啤酒，我已经准备好上场了。把我换上去。
Did Ty Cobb actually spike you, babe, when he slid into, yes he did. Well, I ate two steaks and took a nap and let's go. I had 16 bottles of beer, let's hit a ball. But think about it, it's 100 years later, you say Babe Ruth, everybody knows. Right? And that's the era before any of sports in its popularity level existed.
泰·柯布（Ty Cobb）滑垒时真的用鞋钉铲过你吗，贝比？是的，他铲过。好吧，我吃了两块牛排，睡了个午觉，我们走吧。我喝了16瓶啤酒，让我们去击球吧。但想想看，100年过去了，你一说贝比·鲁斯，人尽皆知。对吧？那是体育运动及其普及程度达到一定水平之前的时代。
So, yeah, talk about a community game. That's the era before any of sports in its popularity level existed. Yeah, talk about a community game. In those days, it really was. It was a team for your little area around there. Can I ask you guys a France question? Has anybody been to Normandy? I have not, I would like to. And Will, I know Will would love to.
所以，是的，谈谈社区比赛吧。那是体育运动及其普及程度达到一定水平之前的时代。是的，谈谈社区比赛吧。在那些日子里，确实如此。那是为你当地的小社区而战的球队。我能问你们一个关于法国的问题吗？有人去过诺曼底吗？我没有，我很想去。而且威尔，我知道威尔一定会喜欢。
He's a real student of history. I am, massive. I would say, and we's a real student of history. I am. Massive. I would say, and we've gone a couple of times, I would say if you had to ask me what's the place you've been as an American that has impacted you, it's going to Normandy. And here we are, 80 years of D-Day, that anniversary in June. And man, when you sit there and see and read and hear the stories, and when you sit there
他是个真正的历史迷。我是，超级喜欢。我想说，而且我们去过好几次，如果要问我作为一个美国人，去过的对你影响最深的地方是哪里，那就是去诺曼底。我们现在在这里，迎来了诺曼底登陆80周年，也就是6月份的那个纪念日。天哪，当你坐在那里看到、读到并听到那些故事时，当你坐在那里
and look at that cemetery with the white churches and the hill, it's one of the most powerful things that I've ever done. And every time I think of France, and we went to do a little pre-Olympic story a few months ago, we went down to Normandy, just to go back. It was the third time I had a chance to be there,
看着那片有白色十字架和山丘的墓园时，那是我做过最具冲击力的事之一。每当我想起法国，几个月前我们去那里做了一个微型的奥运前瞻故事，我们去了诺曼底，只是为了重游故地。那是我第三次有机会去那里，
and it is the most powerful thing, anybody who's listening, if you ever are blessed enough to be in France, you have the chance to go, as an American, you need to go. But just the geography, that bluff, what they were up against, just the physicality of that. They all had all those, some of those beaches were, and some of those stories that were never,
它是最具冲击力的事，任何在听的听众，如果你有幸去法国，你有机会去的话，作为一个美国人，你必须去。但仅仅是地理环境、那道峭壁、他们所面对的困境，那种身体上的对抗。他们所有人都有那些，有些海滩曾经是，还有一些从未被……
that haven't been told widely, too, there are some of those stories that haven't been, but it's an incredible, I agree with you. I've never been to Normandy, I can't believe it, it's strange. Yeah, I love it, I'm gonna go. Because I do, I have read so much about it. Work that into your trip on your way to go see Mike
从未被广泛讲述的故事，有一些故事还未曾，但这是一段不可思议的经历，我同意你的看法。我从来没去过诺曼底，真难以置信，太奇怪了。对，我很喜欢，我要去。因为我确实读了太多关于它的书了。把这个行程安排进你去见迈克的路上
in the booth in Paris. On your way coming up to see us. I'm coming to see Mike, well I gotta go to Portugal, so I'm gonna, Mike will compare it. Okay, let's see if you can work it in. Thank you for an hour of your professional time. Yeah, this is a new personal time. Mike Turrico. Very, very nice to meet you. work it in thank you for an hour of your professional Very nice to meet you
在去巴黎解说台的路上。在来看我们的路上。我要去看迈克，好吧，我得去葡萄牙，所以我会，迈克会对比一下。好吧，看看你能不能把它安排进行程。谢谢你花了一个专业的时间。对，这是新的私人时间。迈克·特里科。非常非常高兴认识你。把它安排进去，谢谢你花了一个专业的时间。非常高兴认识你
Rico this was an honor guys. Thank you. Keep keep making this laugh. Will you please? Thanks? Oh, well you keep delivering these stories. All right. Thank you, buddy. We'll see on the TV soon for sure Thanks, guys. Thank you. See you Mike. Bye Well, I mean that that guy, you know. Nice, he's a good conversationalist. Well, he's a professional on-air fella. Yeah, he's on-air on television. I tell you what, people say, what kind of superhero power would you like?
里科，这真是我的荣幸，伙计们。谢谢。请继续让我们笑好吗？谢谢？哦，好吧，请继续分享这些故事。好的。谢谢你，老弟。我们很快就会在电视上见面，一定的。谢谢，伙计们。谢谢。再见，迈克。拜。好吧，我的意思是那家伙，你知道的。不错，他是个很好的健谈者。好吧，他是个职业的广播电视人。对，他是电视上的广播员。跟你说吧，人们会问，你想要什么超能力？
Well, I'd like to fly. What kind of job would you like? If I could pick one job, I think I'd take his job. You love that. Well, it's just he touches... I thought you said that about late night TV. Well, but I don't get to go to... I thought you said that about doing a multi-cam...
嗯，我想飞。你想要什么工作？如果我可以选择一份工作，我想我会选他的工作。你太喜欢那个了。好吧，只是他接触到……我以为你对深夜脱口秀也是这么说的。好吧，但我没法去……我以为你对做多机位……
Sick of it. I guess I want a bunch of jobs. But this one... Why don't you just enjoy what you got? You're right, that's a good note. Sorry. No, sorry, tell me about it. You get to go to like every single great event
听腻了。我想我想要一堆工作。但这个……你为什么不享受你已经拥有的呢？你说的对，这提醒得好。抱歉。不，抱歉，跟我说说。你可以去几乎每一个伟大的活动
in the best seat possible, and then he'd get to talk to the people who won right afterwards. Yeah, that is pretty cool. It's pretty cool. I like my job in that I get to sit and listen to have him describe it to me. Right.
坐在尽可能最好的座位上，然后他还能去采访刚刚获胜的人。对，那确实挺酷的。挺酷的。我喜欢我的工作，因为我可以坐下来听他向我描述。对。
It feels like so, such a luxury. Yeah, you know, get him to like walk me through it and... There is something like cozy about what you're saying, Jason, I think, or Will, I can't remember. And he does, for any of you out there that are still listening to this episode that are not sports fans, which I hope there's still many, hopefully you agree that this guy,
感觉太奢侈了。对，你知道的，让他带我过一遍……杰森，我觉得你刚才说的话有种温馨的感觉，或者说是威尔，我记不清了。而且他确实，对于你们这些仍然在听这一集但又不是体育迷的人来说（我希望这样的人还有很多），希望你们也会同意这家伙，
the reason you kinda like him is because you might watch a sporting event that you don't really like or know how the sports play but he's kind of explaining it to you and he kind of, he's got, it's a familiar cozy kind of voice and presence that I guess is a talent. That's kind of where I was going with that. That's what you were about to say. But I said it longer and more boringly. And interrupted him.
你有点喜欢他的原因是因为你可能会看一场你并不真的喜欢或不懂怎么玩的体育比赛，但他会为你解释，他有点，他有一种熟悉、温馨的声音和存在感，我想这是一种天赋。这就是我刚才想表达的意思。那是你正要说的话。但我说得更长、更无聊。而且打断了他。
But you know, he covers all the sports, right? Like he covers... Here it comes. Oh know, he covers all the sports, right? Like he covers... Here it comes. Oh no, he's the NFL... You can always sniff it out because whoever's going to do it tees themself up. They just nudge their way in and go, oh yeah, but... Well, he calls all the sports during the year, but he's going to be the host of the Olympics, but he's not going to be doing any play by play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play
但你知道，他报道所有的体育项目，对吧？就像他报道……来了。哦不，他报道所有的体育项目，对吧？就像他报道……来了。哦不，他是NFL……你总能察觉到，因为谁要这么说，他们就会自己起个话头。他们只是挤进来然后说，哦对，但是……好吧，他一年到头解说所有的体育项目，但他将成为奥运会的主持人，不过他不会做任何实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况解说实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况实况足球实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况实况足球实况实况实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球实况足球实况足球实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况实况足球2024游戏内容介绍：
play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play
播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放 播放
play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play play SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico and Michael Granteri. SmartList. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus
SmartList 是由 Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbico 和 Michael Granteri 100% 有机手工制作的。SmartList。如果您喜欢 SmartList，现在可以通过加入 Wondry Plus 抢先收听且无广告
in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. It's all a lighthearted nightmare on our podcast, Morbid. We're your hosts. I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky and part comedy. The stories we cover are well researched, he claimed and confessed to officially killing up to 28 people, with
在Wondry应用或Apple Podcasts上收听。在您离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey填写简短问卷来告诉我们关于您的信息。在我们的播客《Morbid》中，这一切都是一场轻松的噩梦。我是您的主持人阿琳娜·厄克特。我是阿什·凯利。我们的节目部分是真实犯罪，部分是灵异惊悚，部分是喜剧。我们报道的故事都经过充分研究，他声称并供认正式杀害了多达28人，其中
a touch of humor, I just like to go ahead and say that if there's no band called malevolent deity that is pretty great, a dash of sarcasm and just garnished a bit with a little bit of cursing. This mother f***er lied. Like a liar. Like a liar. And if you're a weirdo like us and love to cozy up to a creepy tale of the paranormal, or you love to hop in the way back machine and dissect the details of some of history's most notorious crimes, you should tune in to our podcast, Morbid.
带点幽默感，我只想先说，如果没有叫“邪恶神明”的乐队，那真是太棒了，再加点讽刺，并以一点粗口点缀。这个杂种撒谎了。就像个骗子一样。就像个骗子一样。如果你像我们一样是个怪胎，喜欢依偎在毛骨悚然的灵异故事旁，或者喜欢坐上时光机剖析历史上一些最臭名昭著的罪案细节，你应该收听我们的播客《Morbid》。
Follow Morbid on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to episodes early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Wondery应用程序或您获取播客的任何地方关注Morbid。您可以通过加入Wondery Plus和Wondery应用程序或在Apple Podcasts上提前且免广告收听节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。